Rồi các bạn ơi, hôm qua chúng ta đang
nói dở những cái đoạn liên quan đến việc
là chúng ta giảm chiều dữ liệu đúng
không? Dimensionality reduction thì qua
mình có nói với các bạn là gì? Đó là
trong machining ấy thì có rất nhiều cái
kỹ thuật về giải dữ liệu. Thế mà nhìn
chung các kỹ thuật này sẽ được nhóm làm
hai cái nhóm chính. Một là feature
selection hay tiếng Việt mình gọi là cho
đọc kháng trưng. Và nhóm thứ hai là
feature extraction hay tiếng Việt mình
gọi là chi suất đặc trưng. Thế thì cái
điểm khác biệt giữa chọn lọc và chi suất
là gì? Là với chọn lọc đặc trưng ấy thì
những cái feature cuối cùng chúng ta giữ
lại ấy nó vẫn là những cái feature trong
cái bộ gốc ban đầu. Trong khi đối với
feature exction hay là chiế suất đặc
trưng ấy thì những cái feature cuối cùng
mà chúng ta giữ lại ấy là những cái
feature đã thông qua quá trình chúng ta
biến đổi, quá trình chúng ta transform
nó rồi. Thế thế nên là với những cái
feature cuối cùng mà chúng ta có được
của feature extction ấy, chúng ta sẽ
không thể chúng ta có thể giải thích là
cái ý nghĩa của nó là gì. Tại vì vản
chất nó đã được biến đổi rồi. Được chưa?
Thế còn đối với feature selection thì
đến những cái feature cuối cùng chúng ta
giữ lại ấy, chúng ta có thể giải thích
được là nó có ý nghĩa gì. Tại vì là suy
cho cùng nó cũng là cái từ cái bộ gốc
ban đầu đúng không?
Thế thì hôm qua chúng ta có đi qua một
vài những cái kỹ thuật cơ bản trong
feature selection rồi. Thì hôm nay chúng
ta sẽ tìm hiểu về feature exction. Đây
các bạn nhìn về minh họa đây đúng không?
Lúc đầu chúng ta có tám feature, bây giờ
tôi biến đổi tôi sang cái chiều không
gian mới tôi chỉ giữ lại có bốn feature
thôi. Thì bốn feature tôi giữ lại ấ nó
không phải là những cái feature góc ban
đầu nên tôi sẽ không thể tôi có thể diễn
tả, tôi có thể mô tả nó bằng cái lời nói
được. Được chưa?
Thế thì thế thì trong
các cái kỹ thuật trong những cái thuật
toán liên quan đến feature extraction ấy
thì một trong số những thuật toán nổi
tiếng nhất được sử dụng rộng mãi nhất là
PCA hay tên đầy đủ là principal
component analyst.
Đây là một bài toán giả chiều dữ liệu
rất kinh điển và được sử dụng rất là
rộng rãi trong machining.
Các bạn tưởng tượng nhá. Ví dụ cái ảnh
bên trái là cái dữ liệu góc ban đầu đúng
không? Ảnh bên trái là dữ lượng góc ban
đầu. Thì dữ liệu gốc ban đầu này nó ở
trong không gian ba chiều được chưa? Thì
bây giờ giả sử tôi muốn giảm nó chỉ về
giảm chiều dữ liệu đi. Tôi muốn đưa về
hai chiều thôi đúng không? Đưa từ ba
chiều về hai chiều tô đã mất mất đi mất
một chiều rồi đúng không? Nhưng mà câu
hỏi đây là bây giờ tôi muốn giảm như vậy
ấ thì tôi
những cái chiều mà tôi giữ lại ấ làm sao
để tôi có thể tìm ra những cái chiều
này? Tại vì chúng ta biết là feature
exction là nó sẽ phải biến đổi đúng
không? Nó không lấy những cái rượu gốc
bằng nó không nó không hoạt động trong
cái không gian gốc ban đầu chúng ta phải
biến đổi trong cái chiều không gian mới.
Vì câu hỏi là trong cái không gian mới
này làm sao để tôi tìm được xem không
gian mới này là không gian mới nào được
chưa?
Thế thì các bạn nhìn này. Ờ
với các cái thuật toán trong machin các
bạn nhớ là lốp chúng ta học ở đầu khóa
này nói về cái bài mà khi chúng ta nói
về tiền xử lý dữ liệu ấy mình có nói với
các bạn là gì? Là với các cái dữ liệu
dạng số ấy chúng ta phải tiền xử lý. Tại
vì sao? Tại vì nếu mà chúng ta không
tiền xử lý thì mô hình nó sẽ ưu tiên
những cái feature nào mà có cái biên độ
giá trị, cái giải giá trị nó rộng. Ví dụ
một ông giá trị từ 1 đến từ 0 đến 1000,
một ông từ 0 đến 10 thì mô hình nó sẽ
tập trung hơn vào cái ông từ 0 đến 1000.
Nó sẽ focus hơn vào cái ông từ 0 đến
1000 để ông đấy có giải giá trị lớn hơn.
Đấy là về các cái thuật toán trong
machining. Tức là các bạn cứ để tự nhiên
thôi là các cái thuật toán tự nhiên là
nó cũng sẽ hầu hết các cái thuật toán
machine nó sẽ đều có cái xu hướng nó sẽ
tập trung focus hơn nó vào những cái
feature của cái giải giá trị nó lớn. Đây
là nói về liên quan đến việc là cái mô
hình nhá. Thế bây giờ mình sẽ nói về một
cái bài toán khác, một cái bài toán liên
quan đến trực quan hóa dữ liệu. Trực
quan hóa dữ liệu có nghĩa là gì? Tức là
bây giờ tôi sẽ vẽ làm sao? Tôi có thể
tôi vẽ tôi sử dụng các cái biểu đồ, các
cái đồ thị để tôi có thể tôi vẽ, tôi mô
phỏng dữ liệu của tôi. Thì các bạn hiểu
này, khi mà chúng ta muốn chư quân hóa
dữ liệu ý thì thông thường là chúng ta
sẽ phải đưa dữ liệu từ không gian nhiều
chiều về không gian ít chiều, đúng
không? Mà cụ thể ở đây chúng ta sẽ phải
đưa rượu từ không gian nhiều chiều.
Nhiều ở đây nó có thể là 5 chiều, 10
chiều, 100, 200, 1000, 1 tỷ, bao nhiêu
chiều tôi không quan tâm. Nó rất là
nhiều chiều. Thế thì
vì sao mà trực văn hóa chúng ta lại phải
đưa về công gian ít chiều rất là dễ hiểu
thôi. Chúng ta biết là gì? Chúng ta sẽ
chỉ có thể trược văn hóa dữ liệu trong
không gian hai chiều hoặc cùng lắm là
không gian ba chiều đúng không? Trong
không gian hai chiều hoặc trong không
gian ba chiều. Có nghĩa là bây giờ dữ
liệu các bạn mà nếu dữ liệu các bạn ấy
nó chỉ có một chiều, hai chiều, ba chiều
thì các bạn có thể chữ con hóa luôn. Các
bạn không cần phải giảm cái gì cả đúng
không? Nếu dữ liệu gốc ban đầu các bạn
chỉ có một cột, hai cột hay ba cột thì
các bạn vẽ được luôn không cần phải làm
gì phức tạp cả. Thế nhưng mà khi mà rượu
các bạn nó nhiều hơn ba chiều đó là bốn
chiều, 5 chiều, 6 chiều, 10 chiều, 100,
1000, 1 tỷ chiều thì lúc này chúng ta
biết là chúng ta sẽ không bao giờ có thể
chứa văn hóa trong cái không gian gốc
đấy. Chúng ta sẽ phải đưa nó về không
gian ít chiều hơn. Được chưa? Thế bây
giờ cái câu hỏi là bây giờ đưa về công
ít chiều thì cụ thể là đưa về những cái
chiều như nào? Thế thì có rất nhiều cách
cận cách tiếp cận khác nhau nhưng cách
tiếp cận phổ biến nhất, cách tiếp cận mà
nhiều luật toán liên quan đến trường
quan dữ liệu ta làm nhất là gì? Là người
ta sẽ đưa về cái những cái chiều nào mà
có cái độ phân tán của dữ liệu nó là lớn
nhất nhá. Cái độ phân tán dữ liệu là lớn
nhất. Thì các bạn nhìn này, ví dụ này,
ví dụ nhá. Những cái điểm rượu gốc ban
đầu lúc đầu nó không có cái màu đâu. Màu
này chỉ cho các bạn dễ nhìn thôi. Màu
xanh đỏ tí vàng cái màu của những cái
hạt tròn tròn này lúc đầu nó không có
cái màu này đâu. Đấy. Thế lúc ban đầu
đây là rượu trong không gian gốc ban đầu
là không gian gốc ban đầu là không gian
chiều là x0 x1 x2. Được chưa? x0 x1 x2.
Thế thì bây giờ ấy tôi muốn giả sử tôi
muốn trực quân hóa nó trong không gian
hai chiều đi được chưa? Thì tôi phải làm
thế nào? Thế bây giờ ấy tôi muốn đưa nó
về trong không gian hai chiều thì có
nghĩa là tôi sẽ phải làm hai bước. Bước
đầu tiên là tôi sẽ chuyển cái không gian
từ cái không gian gốc bao gồm ba cái
chiều là x0, x1, x2 này sang một cái
chiều không gian mới cũng có ba chiều
đúng không? Tôi chuyển dữ liệu từ một
không gian ba chiều gốc sang một không
gian ba chiều đích. Cái không gian ba
chiều đích này nó sẽ phải đảm bảo cái
điều là gì? Là dữ liệu của tôi nó phải
phân tán tối đa qua các cái trục của
tôi, qua các cái chiều của tôi Ox, Oy,
OZ ấy. Được chưa? Trong chiều không th
gốc ban đầu ấy, X0, X1, X2 thì ở mỗi một
cái chiều nó đều có cái độ phân tán nhất
định. Ví dụ đây các bạn thấy là theo cái
chiều x0 có vẻ nó phân tán nhiều nhất.
X1 phân tán ít hơn ít hơn x2 là phân tán
ít nhất đúng không? Thế bây giờ tôi sẽ
phải đưa nó sang một cái không gian mới
để làm sao cho không gian này ở mỗi một
cái chiều ấy, mỗi một cái trục của tôi
ấy, rượu tôi nó phân án tối đa. Thế ví
dụ các bạn nhìn thấy ở đây cái chiều
không gian mới, chiều không gian đích ấy
được biểu thị bởi cái ờ bởi cái hệ độ ba
cái đường màu xanh nước biển, màu đỏ,
màu xanh lá cây này đúng không? Thì các
bạn thấy là ví dụ đây các bạn nhìn thấy
trong cái hình này theo cái trục của cái
màu xanh nước biển này thì cái độ phân
tán của rượu nó là maximum. Được chưa?
Sau đó là cái theo cái chiều của màu đỏ
ít hơn một chút. Cái chiều màu xanh lá
cây là cái chiều ít nhất. Thế thì rõ
ràng là dữ liệu của tôi trong ba cái
chiều này, trong cái không gian mới này,
trong ba cái chiều này thì cái chiều màu
xanh nước biển và màu đỏ cái độ phân tán
của rượu nó lớn hơn là màu xanh lá cây.
Do đó bây giờ để trực văn hóa thì tôi sẽ
trực quá trong gian hai chiều thì tôi sẽ
giữ lại hai cái chiều hai cái trục mà độ
phân tán nó lớn hơn là cái trục màu xanh
nước biển và màu xanh và màu đỏ. Đấy sẽ
là cây tôi bỏ đi. Được chưa? Tôi sẽ được
như này. Vì sao khi chư quân hóa tôi lại
giữ lại những cái ông phân tán lớn thì
nó cũng dễ hiểu thôi. Các bạn cứ tưởng
tượng này. Bây giờ các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây
giờ các bạn đang đứng ở một cái vị trí
trên cao. Các bạn nhìn vào một cái nhóm
50 người. 50 người này ấy mà họ cứ đứng
túm tụm vào một chỗ ấy thì các bạn sẽ
rất là khó để các bạn phân biệt được
người này với người kia đúng không? 50
người mà người ta đứng túng tụm một chỗ
rất là khó để phân biệt họ. Thế nhưng
bây giờ nếu mà họ tản ra, họ tản ra các
cái chỗ khác nhau họ đứng khi họ phân
tán ra rồi ấy thì các bạn nhìn họ sẽ rất
là dễ và các bạn sẽ dễ phân biệt người
này với người kia hơn. Hoặc là giống như
kiểu trong bóng đá ấy, trong bóng khá
các bạn thấy trong bóng đá cái tình
huống phát góc ấy đúng không? Mọi người
đứng túm tụm lại ở cái vòng cấm địa ấy
thì sẽ nhìn phân biệt họ rất là khó.
Nhưng mà khi mà bóng được phát lên rồi
mọi người tản ra đi thì nhìn nó sẽ dễ
hơn đúng không? Thì với con người chúng
ta dữ liệu nó cứ ta càng phân tán chúng
ta phân biệt chúng nó càng dễ đúng
không? Nhìn nó càng dễ. Thế nên do đó
khi mà chúng ta muốn chư quán dữ liệu
người ta cũng sẽ ưu tiên người ta tìm
những cái chiều nào mà cái độ phân tái
diện nó lớn. Được chưa? Thì đấy chính là
cái ý tưởng của PCA đúng không? Trong
cái chiều không gian gốc ban đầu x0x m2
thì x0x m2 nó cũng có những cái độ phân
tán nhất định rồi nhưng độ phân tán đây
nó chưa phải tối ưu thì nhiệm vụ tôi là
tôi phải tìm ra những cái không gian
mới. Mà trong không gian mới này rượu
tôi nó sẽ có cái độ phân tán là tối đa
qua các cái chiều của tôi. Được chưa?
Không gian bớt gốc ban đầu cũng là ba
chiều. Không gian đích cũng là ba chiều.
Nhưng mà trong ba cái chiều này tôi sẽ
giữ lại hai cái chiều nào mà độ phân tán
nó là lớn nhất. Được chưa? Thì khi bạn
chấn hóa lên nó như này được chưa? Cái
trục màu xanh lá cây độ phân tán nó rất
là ít. Nếu mà các bạn vẽ theo cái trục
màu xanh lá cây này các bạn nhìn rất là
khó thì nó cứ túm tụp lại vào với nhau.
Nên tôi sẽ giữ lại hai cái trục là trục
màu xanh nước biển với cả trục màu đỏ.
Được chưa? Thế đấy là cái ý tưởng của
PCA.
Ý tưởng của PCA được chưa? Đây là một
thuật toán. Về mặt bản chất nó là một
tuột toán thuộc cái nhóm là feature
extraction. Tức là tôi chi đặc trưng.
Tôi hoàn toàn tôi có thể dùng nó thì tôi
lắp vào trong cái pipeline của Merching.
Ví dụ cái chỗ mà dùng select Kback ấy
các bạn thay vì dùng select Kback các
bạn dùng cái PCA thì cũng được. Đấy. Thế
nhưng mà PCA người ta
dùng rất nhiều trong trực văn hóa tại vì
cái tính chất của nó là như vậy. Tính
chất của nó là nó giúp chúng ta tìm ra
cái chiều nào dệu nó phân tán nhất. Càng
phân tán các bạn nhìn phân biệt nó càng
dễ. Được chưa?
Đấy là về
đấy là về PCA tuổi toán liên quan đến
giảm chiều dữ liệu và vì tôi giảm đúng
không? Nếu mà tôi giảm đến còn hai chiều
với ba chiều là tự nhiên tôi sẽ chư quân
hóa được đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn có
lúc đầu có 100 chiều các bạn giảm về 10
chiều thì các bạn sẽ đưa được vào trong
mô hình machining. Nếu các bạn giảm tiếp
về hai chiều hoặc ba chiều là các bạn
ngoài việc các bạn đưa vào trong mô hình
machining các bạn có thể chữ văn hóa các
bạn phải vẽ nó lên nữa. Được chưa?
Thế thì vừa nãy mình vừa có nói về cái
việc là dữ liệu nó càng phân tán càng dễ
nhìn đúng không? Cả con người chúng ta
và cả các cái mô hình AI ấy nó đều ưa
thích cái sự phân tán này. Đều ưu thích
sự phân tán này. Các bạn để ý nhá.
Ngày xưa lúc các bạn học cái môn só
thống kê các bạn học về công thức về kỳ
vọng phương sai về đồ định chuẩn đúng
không? Thì đây công thức của phương sai
này varian này đúng không? Phương sai
đúng không? Bằng e của x bình trừ đi x
bình phương. Phương sai của một biến mẫu
nhân x nó thể hiện cái điều gì? Nó thể
hiện cái mức độ phân tán của các cái giá
trị xung quanh giá trị kỳ vọng đúng
không? Kỳ vọng là giá trị trung bình
đương đứng ở giữa. Vì các cái ông kia
phân tán nó càng nhiều. Ví dụ là điểm
trung bình của lớp là 7 điểm. Thế nếng
mà cái variant nó bé thì có nghĩa là các
cái điểm mọi người nó lă quanh là chỉ 6
đến 8 điểm. Còn varian nó lớn nó sẽ
quanh là từ 4 đến 10 điểm. Kiểu kiểu như
vậy. Được chưa? Thế thì vì sao mà cả con
người lẫn mô hình nó lại nó lại thích
cái sự phân tán lớn, cái biên độ phân
tán nó lớn? Tại vì là nó nó dễ phân biệt
với nhau. Các bạn có tưởng tượng bây giờ
các bạn có ba đứa bạn thân đúng không?
Một đứa tên là Alex, một đứa tên là Ben
và một đứa tên là Chris. Thì bây giờ ấy
ba cái đứa này ấ mà chiều cao nó rất
khác biệt nhau rất là nhiều. Một ông
1,45, một ông 1,85. Thì bây giờ giả sử
bây giờ người ta đọc một cái tên chiều
cao của một ông, đọc cái số liệu chiều
cao của một ông thì các bạn sẽ rất là dễ
phân biệt được là ông nào với ông nào.
Tại vì trúng chiều cao rất là khác biệt
đúng không? Khi ba đứa này chiều cao nó
khác nhau nhiều, các bạn phân biệt chúng
rất là dễ. Nhưng mà bây giờ giả thứ các
bạn có ba đứa các bạn tên là Daniel EA
với cả Fernandz thì cao chúng nó xêm xêm
với nhau thì bây giờ khi nó cứ xêm xêm
nhau này các bạn phân biệt rất là khó
đúng không các bạn? Không biết là cụ thể
đứa nào là m72 đứa m73 đúng không? Nhìn
rất là khó tại vì là chúng nó cái độ
phân tán nó không có nhiều được chưa?
Thế với con người như thế nào mô hình nó
cũng y chang như thế mô hình nó cũng sẽ
ưa chuộn những cái thứ gì nó độ phân tán
lớn đúng không? Đấy thế nên là nếu mà
khi mà chúng ta trực quân hóa chẳng hạn
hoặc chúng ta chọn ph chúng ta sẽ ưa trụ
những cái ông mà có cái variền nó lớn
được chưa? Đấy.
Ờ
nói về variance rồi, chúng ta sẽ nói về
một cái khái niệm nữa là covariance.
Variant thì là phương sai.
Còn covariance tiếng Việt gọi là cái gì
các bạn nhỉ? Covarient tiếng Việt gọi là
gì?
Trong sáu suất thống kê covariance tiếng
Việt gọi là gì các bạn?
Việt gọi là gì? Hiệp phương sai. Đúng
rồi. Phương sai là độ phân tán của một
biến. Còn hiệp phương sai độ phân tán
của hai biến. Đúng khi chúng ta consider
hai biến, chúng ta cân nhắc hai biến.
Đúng không? Covidence là của hai biến.
Covalence là hiệp phương sai. Còn
correlation là hệ số tương là là tương
quan đúng không? Cái quan hệ giữa
covariance và coration hay là quan hệ
giữa hiệp phương sai với cả tương quan
là gì? Thì hiệp phương thì tương quan
tương quan của hai biến nó là phiên bản
chuẩn hóa của phương sai. Cái mối quan
hệ các bạn nhìn này. Tương quan thì bằng
hiệp phương sai chia cho tích của độ
lệch chuẩn giữa hai biến.
Thế nếu mà giá trị của câu variant, giá
trị của hiệp phương sai ấy nó nằm trong
khoảng từ âm vô cùng đến dương vô cùng
thì cái giá trị của coration ấy thì nó
sẽ nằm trong khoảng từ -1 cho đến 1.
Đấy. Thì các bạn nhìn đây cái so sánh
đây là bảng so sánh giữa
covariance và correlation. Câu variance
là hiệp phương sai. Cả hai ông này thì
đều dùng để đánh giá xem là hai cái biến
ngẫu nhiên ấy nó có cái mối quan hệ
tuyến tính hay không. Và nếu có là theo
chiều dương hay là theo chiều âm. Chiều
dương tức là đồng biến tức là ông tăng
tôi tăng, ông giảm tôi giảm. Đấy. Còn
chiều âm là nghịch biến, tức là ông tăng
tôi giảm và ngược lại. Được chưa?
Cả hai ông đều thể hiện cái điều này đều
thể hiện là hai biến mố gọi tuyến tính
hay không. Còn nếu có theo chiều gì. Thế
nhưng mà riêng coration ấy thì nó sẽ thể
hiện được một cái nữa là cái độ mạnh của
mối quan hệ tuyến tính. Covarient nó
không thể hiện được. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
covarient nó không có nó không được
chuẩn hóa. Covariance giá trị nằm trong
khoảng từ âm vô cùng đến dương vô cùng.
Nó không được chuẩn hóa. Thế nên là khi
mà các bạn nhìn vào cái giá trị của
covarient ví dụ là 100 đi các bạn cũng
không biết là 100 là nhiều hay là ít.
Tại vì là nó đâu chuẩn hóa đâu. Về mặt
kỹ thuật là nó có thể lên đến dương vô
cùng mà. Được chưa? Thế thế còn
correlation nó sẽ chuẩn hóa corelation
là chỉ nằm trong khoảng từ -1 cho đến 1
thôi. Được chưa? Thế là chúng ta biết là
gần -1 với gần 1 có nghĩa là mạnh, gần 0
nghĩa là yếu. Được chưa? Đấy. Đấy các
bạn ông đấy là cái sự khác biệt giữa hai
ông này được chưa? Một ông hai ông đều
thể hiện được mối quan hệ đều thể hiện
được cái hướng của mối quan hệ tuyến
tính nhưng chỉ có coration thể hiện được
cái độ mạnh của nó thôi.
Thế vì sao lại nói về vì sao mình lại
nói về covarient ở đây? Tại vì là
covarian nó là một cái bước chúng ta có
thể tính được.
Chúng ta có thể
chúng ta có thể
tính được cái công thức của PCA nó sẽ
qua bước là các bạn phải sử dụng liên
quan đến
liên quan đến
liên quan đến câu variance.
Trước khi chúng ta đi tiếp vào cái phần
này thì hôm nọ có một bạn xem qua record
các bạn ấy bạn ấy hỏi mình là sao anh
lại không nói tiếp về cái phần liên quan
đến computer vision các bạn chờ tí mình
mở nhá.
Các bạn chờ tí mình mở bài trang.
Các bạn có biết là vì sao không? Hôm nãy
mình để ngắt quãng không? Tại vì là hôm
nấy lớp hỏi qua trả lời đâu.
Hôm nãy hỏi qu ai trả lời đâu? Hôm nãy
hỏi cả lớp hôm nay có mấy chục bạn mà mà
trả qua trả lời nên mình chán qua mình
bỏ qua. Nhưng mà thôi các bạn xem qu bạn
ấy hỏi thì thôi chúng ta lại đá qua đá
lại một tí nhá. Có nhanh thôi các bạn.
Chờ tí mình mở à
nấy cả lớp phải đến mấy bạn mà vào mà
hỏi chả chả chả bạn nào biết.
Các bạn chờ tí nhá mình à mình mở bài
trang một phát đã.
À đâu nhở? Machine
mình đã định là nếu mà không ai hỏi thì
thôi luôn. Coi như là bỏ qua luôn đấy mà
thôi có bạn hỏi rồi thì thôi cũng không
thoát được.
Chờ một tí nhá. Mình à mở lại project
đã.
đâu ấy nhỉ?
Hôm nọ như mình lại xóa mình lại xóa xử
cái code nó đang viết giờ chắc lại phải
ngồi viết lại rồi.
Các bạn chờ tí nhá mình đang mở vai
trang nó hơi lag một tí.
Nhắc lại về bài toán nhá. Phải nói lại
đi lại một lần nữa nhá.
Chúng ta có cái bộ rượu là bộ. Đây là
cái bộ rượu vỡ lòng dành cho những ai
người ta học về cái mảng gọi là Deep
Learning for computer vision. Cái bộ này
thì bao gồm hai tập con là tập train và
tập test.
Tập trin thì có à cái bộ này là cái bộ
về những cái bảng
rồi hôm nọ xóa thừ rồi lại một tí ngồi
viết lại rồi.
Cái bộ này là cái bộ
này tắt bớt đi.
Cái bộ này là cái bộ mà chúng ta có hai
bộ là bộ truyên với bộ test.
Bộ trên là có 60.000 ảnh
và bộ test là có 10.000 ảnh. Được chưa?
Bộ train có 60.000 ảnh, bộ test có
10.000 ảnh.
Các cái ảnh này đều là những ảnh của các
cái bản chữ viết tay, các cái số từ 0
cho đến 9. Thế thì các cái ảnh này nó
đều ảnh kích thước rất là bé. Độ phân
giải của chúng đều là kích thước là ờ 60
x 60 tất cả à xin lỗi bạn 28 x 28 nhá.
Tất cả đều là 28 x 28 cả được chưa? Ảnh
nó đều là nền đen chữ trắng như này.
Được chưa? Hôm nọ mình có nói các bạn là
gì? Đó là trong Computer Vision ấy thì
chúng ta có rất nhiều loại ảnh khác
nhau. Trong đó có hai loại ảnh phổ biến
là ảnh đen trắng với cả ảnh màu. Ảnh đen
trắng thì chúng ta sẽ lưu chữ nó bằng
một cái mảng hai chiều. Đây ảnh đen
trắng các bạn sẽ lưu chữ nó bằng một cái
mảng hai chiều như thế này.
Đấy. Một cái mảng hai chiều thế này.
Chiều cao với chiều ngang đúng không?
Mỗi một cái pixel sẽ có một cái giá trị
là từ mỗi một cái pixel này sẽ có một
cái giá trị là từ 0 cho đến 255.
0 là màu đen, 255 là màu trắng càng gần
0 càng đen, càng gần 25 thì càng trắng
đúng không? Nó mình nói rồi. Được chưa?
Cái bộnis nó như thế này. Cái bộnis thì
nó có
rất nhiều cách để các bạn có thể
download. Đây là bộ dưỡng rất là phổ
biến. Rồi thì hôm nọ mình có gửi cho các
bạn cái file đuôi NPZ đúng không? Đấy là
cái file dữ liệu dạng à đặc biệt của NP.
Đây cái file này chấm này. Được chưa?
Hôm nọ mình cái script nọ mình xóa xử
rồi tại mình mới viết lại đấy
nhá. Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ viết lại cái
script để chúng ta đọc cái dượng này vào
nhá.
Classification. Được chưa? Thì mục tiêu
của mình bây giờ là gì? Mục tiêu của
mình bây giờ mình muốn
mình muốn huấn luyện một cái mô hình để
làm sao cái mô hình này sau này khi
chúng ta đưa vào input là một cái bản vẽ
viết tay của một cái số nào đó thì mô
hình của mình nó sẽ dựn được xem là cái
số này nó là số gì. Về mặt bản chất nó
là bài toán phân loại thôi. Nó là bài
toán classification được chưa? Có 10
class để phân biệt giữ 10 class này được
chưa? Nó giống như là bài bộ di nó chỉ
có hai class thôi hoặc là cái bộ về job
nó có sáu class thì cái bộ này nó có 10
class thế thôi. Được chưa? Bây giờ các
các bạn có cái file
ơ mình có rồi à à đây đây cái file nó nọ
dở đây này. Đây nọ đang viết dở đây.
Được chưa? Chạy lại nhá.
Chạy lại nhá.
Đây này. Đây là cái chỗ nội tức này. Cái
chỗ mình tức là ở chỗ là mình hỏi các
bạn xem là làm này xong là làm cái gì
tiếp. Cả lớp không có ai trả lời được
đây này.
Đây hôm nọ chúng ta đọc rượu xong sau đó
hỏi cả lớp là bây giờ đọc rượu xong rồi
làm gì tiếp cả lớp ngồi im. Hỏi 5 phút
xong và lớp ngồi im không ai trả lời.
Thế nên mình bảo thôi bỏ qua mình chạy
lại nhá. Các bạn thấy không? Cái file
này ấ là người ta đã nén tất cả dữ liệu
ở bên trong rồi. Bộ trin, bộ test này,
xin, e trin này, x test này, test này.
Được chưa các bạn? Chờ tí mình load cho
các bạn xem nhá.
Nhớ nhá. Là cái bộ anx này ấ các cái ảnh
đều kích thước là 28 x 28 pixel. Tất cả
đều 28 x 28. Nền đen chữ trắng. Đen thì
gần đen này là gần 0 trắng là gần 255
càng gần đen thì càng gần số 0 càng gần
trắng càng gần 255 được chưa? À lần đầu
các bạn chạy cho chút nó sẽ phải
các bạn chờ một chút nhá. Lần đầu lần
đầu nó lốt nó sẽ phải à xử lý một chút.
Thế thì à cái bộ này ấy thì cái a cái
rượu gốc thì nó cái cái nguồn gốc của nó
thì bây giờ chúng ta không có vào nữa
tại vì bây gi khóa mất rồi. Nhưng mà các
bạn có rất nhiều nguồn các bạn đ về đây
này. Các bạn có thể đ trên KG nhiều
nguồn lắm.
Có nhiều nguồn khác nhau các bạn. Có
nhiều cách để các bạn có thể download
trúng. Đây mà cái đây bộ Mix đây. Đây
cũng phải cũng không phải cái bộ gốc
đâu. Bộ gốc thì nó có nhiều cách khác
nhau đúng không? nó có thể đuôi file,
đuôi GZ các thứ rất nhiều cách khác nhau
các bạn down nó về. Đấy nhưng mà tóm lại
là gì? Là
tất cả nó đều là kích thước là 28 x 28
đúng không? Bộ trin có 60.000. Bộ trên
60.000 tức là mỗi class sẽ có khoảng
6000 nhưng mà nó sẽ không đúng 6000 đâu.
Có ông thừa một tí, có ông bớt một tí.
Bộ test cũng thế. 10.000 Nhìn tức là mỗi
cái bass 1000 nhưng mà không phải đúng
1000 đâu mà mỗi ông có sẽ ông thừa có
thể ông lên nghìn nghìn bao nhiêu mỗi
ông thì 900 trăm mấy ví dụ như vậy nó sẽ
không nó sẽ không bằng nhau chắc chẳn
chặn thì các bạn nhìn nhá đây ví dụ đây
bây giờ mình
các bạn nhìn nhá thế bây giờ giả sử bây
giờ mình chạy nhá
chạy thử này
khi Khi mà các bạn load nó ra ấy nó sẽ
những cái n array nó những cái bảng đa
chiều được chưa?
Bảng đa chiều các bạn chờ đi mình sẽ
show bạn xem ảnh trông như thế nào nhá.
Chờ một xíu lần đầu chạy nó hơi lâu.
Đây chờ tí nhá. Nó hiện ra ở đây nàyy
đây nhá.
Bộ train của mình nó sẽ là một cái 5
array đây. 5 array này. Một cái mảng ba
chiều chiều đầu tiên là 60.2828 được
chưa? Xt test cũng là 5 paray 10.000
2828 60.000 với 10.000 là số lượng
simple đấy. Còn label nó chỉ như này
thôi. Label nó chỉ là một cái mảng
60.000 hoặc 10.000 thôi. Được chưa?
Đấy. Thế bây giờ ví dụ đi. Mình lấy một
cái ảnh ra.
Ví dụ nhá, mình lấy một cái ảnh ra. Ví
dụ mình lấy cái ảnh đầu tiên của bộ
train đi. Được chưa? Image
bằng x train. Mình lấy cái ảnh đầu tiên
nhá. Cảnh đầu tiên này mình sẽ lấy ra
cái lel tương ứng
bằng i trên 0 nhá.
Mình sẽ in ra print này,
image này và print ra cho các bạn xem là
cái ảnh trông như thế nào nhá. Ảnh này
là ảnh đen trắng kích thước kích thước
nó bé nên nhìn nó vẫn sẽ tương đối dễ.
Các bạn chờ một tí này.
Các bạn nhìn này. Cái ảnh này à không
nhìn này nó sẽ hơi khó.
Đó. Đây chỗ này thôi
nhá. Label thì là số 5 nó là ảnh số 5.
Ảnh của số 5 luôn. cái image nhá các bạn
nhìn này.
Đây các bạn nhìn này. Nét của số 5 này.
Thấy chưa? Số 5 đấy. Được chưa? Cái phần
nào mà
cái phần nào mà không có nét thì nó sẽ
là gần với 0. Đây còn gần có nét gần số
5 này. Được chưa? Số 5 này. Được chưa?
Xong mình chọn một cái số khác nhá. Mình
chọn cái số khác nhá. Ví dụ mình để cái
index ở đây đi.
Bằng 100 đi. Được chưa?
Cho index vào đây.
Next vào đây. Được chưa?
Xem số khác nhá. À vẫn vẫn là số 5 cho
số to hẳn đi.
Được chưa?
Nhìn nhá.
Ơ
sao lấy kiểu gì cũng ra số 5 thế nhỉ?
À
lấy số khác chứ nhỉ?
Số 8 được chưa? Số 8 này. Được chưa? Cái
image của mình nhá. Các bạn nhìn này. Số
số 8 này. Này dống số 8 chưa? Lấy số 8
đấy. Được chưa? Đấy số 8 đây. Vòng số 8
các bạn thấy không? Chỗ nào mà gần với
cái nền màu đen thì nó gần với số 0. Hai
cái thứ này chỗ nào mà gần với nét đi
qua là nó số nó là màu trắng. Chỗ này nó
nó phải là màu trắng đấy. Chẳng qua là
cái P cham thì nó hiển thị số to là màu
tím thôi chứ còn cái nét này nó là màu
nó là màu trắng đấy. Được chưa? Số 8
này. Được chưa? Đấy được chưa? Thì đấy
là cái rượu của chúng ta.
Thế bây giờ các bạn bảo là bây giờ sau
nào? Vẫn câu hỏi lần trước. Câu hỏi
trước chúng ta dừng ở đây. Câu hỏi mình
là sau khi load được dữ liệu rồi, việc
tiếp theo chúng ta làm là chúng ta sẽ
làm cái gì?
Sau khi load được dữ liệu rồi tiếp theo
chúng ta làm sẽ là cái gì? Normal. Đúng
là một ý tưởng đúng không? Phải normal
đúng không? Normalize dữ liệu của chúng
ta.
Đầu tiên nói về normalize, nói về chuẩn
hóa đúng không? Giống như kiểu là chúng
ta dùng với cái bộ đi. Đấy, chúng ta
chuẩn hóa về những cái cột pancen
glucoser các thứ đúng không? Các bạn cho
mình hỏi này, trong cái trường hợp này
à đúng rồi đúng không? Trong những cái
bài trước ấy chúng ta chuẩn hóa tại vì
sao? Tại vì rượu nó trong cái giải khác
nhau. Nhưng mà trong cái bài này ấy thì
chuẩn hóa nó là không cần thiết. Tại vì
sao? Tại vì là các cái pixel giá trị đều
nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 25 năm rồi.
Giải giá trị nó là giống nhau nên thực
ra chúng ta cũng không cần thiết phải
chuẩn pháo cho lắm.
Thật ra thì bình thường ấy cái việc
chuẩn thoại cái việc mà người ta ví dụ
là có thể có một cái bước là chuyển từ 0
đến 25 từ thành từ 0 đến 1 để sau này nó
tránh bị tràn số. Tức là có những cái số
giá trị nó lớn quá nó bị tràn số thôi.
Thấy chứ còn cái việc là chúng nó chuẩn
hóa để cho các cái feature các cái pixel
xong cùng một giải là không cần thiết.
Tại vì là ngay từ đầu chúng nó cũng đã
cũng đã
chúng nó cũng đã cùng một giải rồi. Được
chưa? Ngay từ đầu chúng ta cũng đã cùng
một giải rồi nh chúng ta không cần thiết
chúng ta phải chuẩn hóa chúng đấy. Đúng
không? không chuẩn hóa này các bạn chú ý
này. Bạn à
bạn Đạt và nói một điểm rất là hay là
gì? Là đưa rượu về chuyển về hai chiều.
Các bạn nhìn này.
Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Rượu của chúng ta ấy X trange với cả X
test đang là dệu ba chiều. Đây là cái
điểm khác biệt với những cái bài trước.
Các bạn nhớ là với những cái bộ như là
bộ DVT hoặc là bộ student score chẳng
hạn thì cái diệu đồ vào chúng ta nó là
mảng hai chiều. Mảng hai chiều thì cái
chiều đầu tiên là số lượng sample đúng
không? Hai chiều là một cái ma trận đúng
không? Số lượng hàng là số lượng sle, số
lượng cột là số lượng fature đấy. Đúng
bạn đưa vào thì ok. Nhưng mà đây các bạn
dữ bạn nó là mảng ba chiều. Mảng ba
chiều như này ấ mà các bạn nhét vào
trong các cái mô hình machining nó sẽ
không chạy được. Thì các cái mô hình
machine nó đ nó nó đều yêu cầu là input
phải là mảng hai chiều. Các bạn nhìn
nhá. Đây này.
Ví dụ là linear ví dụ là linear
regression đi các bạn nhìn này. Và yêu
cầu là gì? Là input đây này. Input là
phải mảng đây đây này.
Hai chiều này. Thấy chưa? Input phải
mảng hai chiều. Ba chiều nó không chạy
được nó phải làm việc với mảng hai
chiều. Thế bây giờ
các cái mình muốn đưa vào các cái mô
hình machining nhưng mà cái rượu mình nó
là mảng ba chiều này thì bây giờ mình
phải đưa nó về mảng hai chiều. Đưa về
mảng hai chiều thì đưa kiểu gì bây giờ?
Theo các bạn bây giờ muốn đưa về mảng
hai chiều thì tôi đưa kiểu gì? Bây giờ
mình muốn đưa về mảng hai chiều đưa kiểu
gì bây giờ?
Bạn nào chỉ mình cách đưa về mảng hai
chiều nà.
Đưa kiểu gì đây?
Nó là khoảng ba chiều. Nó là 5 array ba
chiều. Muốn đưa về hai chiều tôi đưa
kiểu gì?
Có ai có ý tưởng gì không?
Muốn đưa về mảng hai chiều ta làm cái
nào?
Để nguyên ba chiều này thì đã đưa vào mô
hình kiểu gì nó báo lỗi. Mô hình nó
không làm việc được với mảng ba chiều,
ba chiều bốn chiều nó không làm được.
Như là được hai chiều thôi.
Flat phát lần flatten như thế nào bây
giờ?
À đúng rồi, mỗi một ảnh nó đang là một
cái ma trận, nó là một cái hình vuông kí
thức là 28 nh 28 pixel. Bây gi mình sẽ
flatten mình sẽ làm phẳng nó ra thành
một cái vận bảng dài ơi là dài đúng
không? 28 nh 28 là 764 thì phải.
28 x 28 à 784 784 đúng không? Tức là gì?
Cái chiều đầu tiên ấy thì giữ nguyên cái
này nó là cái back size nó là nó xin lỗi
bạn nó không phải back size nó là số
lượng sample. Số sample phải giữ nguyên
nó vẫn là 60.000 ảnh chẳng qua là bây
giờ các cái phần pixel tôi sẽ làm phẳng
tôi sẽ có dài ra được chưa thế làm như
vậy thì tôi sẽ có cái hàm là hàm
trong 5 có hàm gì để chúng ta làm chúng
ta chuyển nó từ 3 chiều về hai chiều các
bạn nhở 5 có cái hàm gì ấy nhỉ
trong 5 có hàm gì
đưa mình muốn đưa từ mảng hai chiều về
mảng hai chiều ba chiều về hai chiều thì
tôi dùng hàm gì bây giờ reshap đúng rồi
chính xác
xin
bằng 5 chv reshavep đúng không
chiều mới đây chiều mới ví dụ các bạn có
thể 60.000 000 đúng không? Em kia là 28
nhân 28
nhưng mà làm ảnh nó xấu. Thường trong
lập trình người ta sẽ né cái việc là
người ta H code như này. Các bạn có thể
làm cách khác nó chuyên nghiệp hơn là
gì? À x.sve 0. Được chưa? Chỗ không phải
x mà xin
0 này đúng không? chiều đầu tiên còn hai
chiều kia nhân với nhau trên shap
trên. Shave 1 nhân với exchange sve 2.
Được chưa? Thì làm này các bạn nhìn ra
kẹ output này
nhìn output nhá. Chiều đầu tiên 60.000
thì giữ nguyên
hai chiều sau cù vào nhau đúng không? 8
28 nh 28 là 7 784
nhưng mà cái chỗ này viết này thì vẫn nó
vẫn dài quá.
Có bạn nào chỉ mình cách viết chỗ này
ngắn hơn không?
Làm sao viết cái chỗ này ngắn hơn? Có
bạn biết cách làm viết ngắn hơn không?
Đây nó đang như thế này. Nó như thế này.
Được chưa? Cái ở bên trong cái phần shap
này viết này nó dài quá 60.000 hai chiều
sau nhân với nhau. Có cái nào viết ngắn
hơn chỗ này không? Chỗ này này viết ngắn
hơn là thế nào?
Có biết cách không?
Có biết cách viết chỗ này ngắn hơn
không? Làm cái nào?
Làm thế nào? Viết viết ngắn hơn chỗ này.
Cái tích này viết ngắn hơn thì làm thế
nào?
Có ai biết không?
Làm thế này nhá.
Không phải 28 nhân x 8 là các bạn HCO
rồi tránh cái việc lập trình chúng ta
chính cái việc chúng ta viết cứng cái số
như vậy đúng không?
Như này này
là xong được chưa? Cái này người ta gọi
là unknown dimension là cái chiều không
biết hoặc là người ta gọi là implicit
dimension là cái chiều không phải là ẩn
mình không biết dịch tiếng nào. Tức là
tức là gì? Cái chiều được ghi là -1 ấy
nó sẽ được tính tự động từ những cái
chiều kia. Ví dụ đây là 60.000 nhá. Chỗ
này các bạn ghi là 10.000 chì nó cũng
lỗi. Tại vì tổng số sle nó không nó
không match đúng không? Trước và sau khi
reset phải giống nhau. Trước reset có từ
này phần tử sau reset nó không lên như
này đúng không? Thì khi các bạn để -1
này nó sẽ tự động tính là à tổng cộng
tôi có là 4.U4
à tôi có 4 tôi có 47.740.000
phần tử thì tôi sẽ phải reset như nào để
cái chiều đầu tiên là 60.000 chiều còn
lại nó sẽ là cái chỗ còn lại đúng không?
Thì các bạn làm như này các bạn đây này
-1 được chưa? Nó tự tính ra bộ chuyên
nào thì bộ test cũng thế.
X test này. X test
được chưa?
In ra đây cho cho chắc nhá. Thì cho chắc
nhá. Win này. Xe shave này. Xshave nhá.
Được chưa? Chả lại này.
Nhớ chưa?
Rồi
reset xong rồi.
Bước tiếp theo làm gì hả các bạn?
Bước tiếp theo chúng ta làm cái gì bây
giờ?
Xong rồi. Đến đây rồi. Làm gì tiếp bây
Ừ đưa vào model thôi đúng không? Còn cái
gì nở đâu đúng không?
Ví dụ mình dùng random chẳng hạn đúng
không là mình dùng đúng không form
learn đúng không chemble
for này được chưa
ngắn thôi. Order bằng
ờ không phải random đi
100 đi được chưa? Pit đây đó là
edit
này được chưa? Giờ mình sẽ in ra mình in
ra m cái mấy cái magic này đúng không?
Form learn. Magic đúng không? Import
confusion magic này. Classification
report này. Được chưa? mình sẽ in ra
nói với cái các cái thực toán trong
machining á.
Đang nói về các cái thực toán trong
machining này á.
Với bài này thì nó phải phục thuộc được
xem là các bạn dùng mô hình gì. Có mô
hình các bạn bắt buộc các bạn phải giảm
chiều đây. Ví dụ đây các bạn đang phải
đang đưa từ ba chiều về hai chiều đây
đúng không? Các bạn đang đưa từ ba chiều
về hai chiều đây. Các bạn pass book các
bạn phải giảm không giảm các bạn không
đưa được vào mô hình đúng không? Có
những tôi đoán các bạn không phải giảm
nhưng với bài tầng này các bạn bắt buộc
phải giảm không giảm thì đưa mình nó lỗi
ngay đúng không? Đưa rượu ba chiều vào
nó sẽ lỗi ngay. Được chưa?
Đây nhá. Thử không đưa này. Thử không
đưa nhá. Đúng không? Thử à mình thử mình
không giảm chiều nhá. Không đưa về hai
chiều nhá. này à giảm kích thước á giảm
kích thước thì nó tùy với cái bài toán
này thực ra là 2828 số lượng feature nó
cũng không phải là nó quá lớn các bạn
giảm cái việc mà các bạn có thể giảm
không các bạn có thể dùng green search
với tức là nó chán trong machining các
bạn chúng ta cũng không có gì đảm bảo là
giảm nó sẽ giúp cho mình nó tốt hơn
chúng ta có thể dùng green search để xem
là liệu giảm có tốt hơn hay không đúng
không ra này chúng ta có thể thử được
tại vì là machine chạy nhanh nhanh đi nó
chạy lâu thì mới khó được chưa
tiếp nhá thì bây giờ ờ đây đúng Ví dụ à
các bạn chờ tí chạy n gì nó cũng báo lỗi
này. Mình mà chưa resap lại mảng ba
chiều kỳ gì nó cũng lỗi
lâu ấy nhỉ.
Ô sao lâu thế nhỉ? Đây các bạn nhìn đây
này. Thấy chưa? Không bao chiều nó không
chạy được đúng không? Bây giờ mình bật
lại này. Được chưa? N thủ chạy thì mình
sẽ in luôn cả
in confusion magic trước.
Class vision report sau chạy thử nhá.
Code nó cũng ngắn thôi đúng không các
bạn không? Code loanh quanh mình có 16
dòng được chưa?
Tất nhiên mình chưa áp dụng green search
chưa làm cái gì đặc biệt cả đâu. Mình
chỉ chạy đơn thuần thôi xem kết quả như
nào.
Confusion magic đi trước này.
Classification report đi sau này nhá.
Chờ một tí nhá. Đ chọn mình bé hơn thì
đấy không sao.
Các bạn nhìn này.
Confusion magic đây.
Classification report đây.
Các bạn có nhận có nhận xét như nào các
bạn?
Các bạn có nhận xét gì về mô hình này,
về bài về bài toán này?
Class số 0 đến số 9 này tốt đúng không?
Điểm rất là cao đúng không? 97 98. Các
bạn nhìn này. Chúng ta nhìn qua một tí.
Chúng ta nhìn qua một tí thì chúng ta
thấy là gì? Là điểm của cái mô hình
random fred này dành cho cái bộ image
này điểm rất là cao chưa? Bộ này bộ em
điểm rất là cao đúng không? Chín mấy này
đúng không? Cái ông thất thấp nhất thì
cũng phải là 96 97 thì đấy điểm rất là
cao.
Cái aquacit nó phải đến 97%.
Thật ra thật ra thì với cái bộnis này ấ
cái điểm như này là điểm khá thấp.
Nếu chúng ta dùng các cái kiến trúc mạng
neuron, mạng neuron tích chập trong deep
learning thì các bạn sẽ được cái điểm là
gần như là tất cả đều là 99 ph 99,9 cả.
điểm rất là cao. Cái ACI nó phải 99,
chín mấy cơ.
Với những cái bài toán đơn giản như này,
với bài toán đơn giản như ví dụ như là
cái bài toán này hoặc là cái bài toán về
job classification lần trước ấy thì đây
là những cái bài toán như mình nói các
bạn rồi. Trong các cái mảng khác nhau
thì cái bài toán phân loại luôn là bài
toán rất là cơ bản. Bài toán phân loại
thì kể cả trong bảng NLP cũng như là
trong bảng computerion thì với những bài
toán đơn giản, những bài toán phân loại,
chúng ta vẫn có thể dùng các cái thuật
toán mering truyền thống. Chúng ta học ở
khóa này để giải quyết bài toán nó hoàn
toàn ok, nó không có vấn đề gì. Thế
nhưng trong thực tế với những cái bài
toán trong hai cái mảng này trong mảng
caption với NP thông thường người ta sẽ
không dùng machin truyền thống tại vì
machin truyền thống nó có rất nhiều
những cái hạn chế.
Ví dụ ngay ở đây các bạn thấy này, ngay
cái việc mà chúng ta phải làm phẳng dữ
liệu như này, đây đã là một cái nhược
điểm trí tử của không chỉ fres mà đây là
nhược điểm của gần như tất cả các cái
thuật toán trong machining.
Cái việc làm phẳng này nó sẽ không tốt
khi các bạn làm việc với dự dạng ảnh và
cả các bạn làm rượu trong rượu dạng bên
bảng LP cũng thế. Ví dụ đây chúng ta nói
về ảnh nhá thì mình sẽ nói các bạn là vì
sao lại không tốt. Nhưng các bạn tưởng
tượng như này.
Các bạn tưởng tượng như này nhá.
Giả sử các bạn có bức ảnh như thế này.
Được chưa? Giả sử các bạn có cái bức ảnh
như thế này được chưa?
Anh h ảnh về cái gì các bạn? Anh h ảnh
về cái về cái gì đây?
Ảnh về cái gì đây các bạn?
Đồ ăn đói không các bạn? Đói đúng không
các bạn? Nhìn này.
Vì sao chúng ta lại nhận ra được đây là
đây là món gì các bạn nhỉ? Đây là lòng
đúng không? Lòng lòng với tiết hay à gan
đúng không? Cái này là gan với lòng đúng
không? Vì sao chúng ta nhìn ra được đây
là đồ ăn? Tại vì cái ảnh này nó được
show ra trong không gian hai chiều. Thật
ra cái ảnh này các bạn lưu chữ nó sẽ là
mảng ba chiều th nó là ảnh màu nhưng mà
chúng ta nhìn nó chỉ là mảng hai chiều
thôi. Chúng ta nhìn được xem đây là ảnh
về cái gì tại vì nó là nằm trong công
dân hai chiều.
Bây giờ các bạn cứ tưởng tượng mà xem.
Bây giờ nếu không phải cái ảnh này mà
bây giờ các bạn làm phẳng nó đi. Tức là
gì? Thì bây giờ các ảnh này ví dụ là
chiều cao của nó nó là khoảng à
chiều cao của nó nó là khoảng ơ đâu rồi
tiên lại tắt mất rồi.
Chiều cao của cái ảnh này nó là rơi vào
khoảng khoảng khoảng à
đâu ấ nhở đây
nhá. Cái ảnh này chiều cao của nó là
1500 pixel chứ là
ờ
à chiều chiều ngang là 1000 x các bạn.
Chiều ngang 1500, chiều dọc là 2000.
Được chưa? Cái ảnh trông nó như thế này.
Thế bây giờ các bạn ưng tượng xem nó bao
gồm có 2000 đúng không? Thì bây giờ giả
sử bây giờ các bạn làm phẳng nó tức là
gì? Các bạn lấy 2000 hàng này các bạn
nỗi vào nhau
thì lúc này khi mà các bạn nhìn vào ảnh
các bạn sẽ không còn nhận ra được là đây
là ảnh về cái gì đúng không? Đấy là về
mặt thị giác chúng ta nhá. Còn bây giờ
phân tích về mặt kỹ thuật nhá. Vì sao
lại như vậy? Thì các bạn tưởng tượng này
có phải là bình thường một cái ảnh
bình thường một cái ảnh như này đâu rồi
nhá. Bình thường một cái ảnh như này
ờ mẽ này nó hơi khó. Ví dụ đây cái ảnh
như này nhá.
Đúng không? Ví dụ một cái ảnh mình vẽ
đơn giản là 6 x 6 đi. Được chưa? Thế có
phải là bình thường với một cái ảnh như
này thì rõ ràng là bây giờ với một cái
pixel ở giữa này đúng không? một cái
pixel ở giữa này thì cái pixel này ấy
cái giá trị của nó nó sẽ có cái mối liên
quan cái mối quan hệ cái tương quan với
tám bông xung quanh đúng không? Nó phải
có cái mối quan hệ này đúng không? Ví dụ
ông này là màu đỏ thì những ông xung
quanh nó cũng phải màu phải xêm xêm chứ
nó không thể nào đang ông màu đỏ lại bị
quây bởi bốn ông à bởi tám ông màu nó
chả liên quan gì thành bởi sá m xanh
được đúng không? Nó sẽ phải có cái sự
hài hòa về mặt màu sắc nó phải có cái sự
nhất quán về mặt kiến trúc về cái mặt độ
thay đổi đúng không? Thì đấy là cái chất
của ảnh. Đấy là lý do mà khi chúng ta
nhìn cái ảnh này đúng không? Không thể
nào chỗ này đang đen cạnh nó lại thành
màu trắng ngay được đúng không? Trừ cái
chỗ phần biên này thì không nói làm gì
nhưng mà phần biên này nó phải đảm bảo
cái độ nhất quán tức là nó phải thay đổi
đồng thời đúng không? Chứ không thể một
pixel ở giữa lại màu lại chả liên quan
gì tám b xung quanh không có chuyện đấy.
Được chưa? Thì đấy là cái thông tin về
cái độ độ liên quan này nó rất là quan
trọng. Thế nhưng mà bây giờ khi g làm
phẳng rồi ấy làm phẳng nó thì nó sẽ
thành một cái vecơ dài ngoằng như này.
Đấy ngoằng như này đúng không? Thì bây
giờ cái ông ở giữa đây các bạn chỉ còn
giữ được cái ông bên trái với ông bên
phải thôi. Ngược
ông ở giữa đây. Ông bên trái ông bên
phải. Được chưa? Còn ba ông ở trên ba
ông ở dưới thì các bạn chịu. Ba ông trên
ba ông dưới chịu các bạn không biết là
nó bay đi đâu rồi. Nó sẽ ở cái chỗ này
này. Nó ở cái chỗ đây. Nó ở chỗ đây này.
Đấy. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được chưa? Thế
cái thông tin về việc là các cái pixel ở
gần nhau có mối quan hệ này ấ này thông
tin này người ta gọi nó là
special.
Information
là gì? Là thông tin về mặt không gian.
Được chưa? Special information là thông
tin về mặt không gian. Thông tin về mặt
không gian là thứ quý giá cho cả người,
cả máy để có thể nhận diện được ảnh.
Chẳng qua là cái bộ này bộ nó rất là dễ.
Thế nên là chấp cả cái việc là nó làm
phc bị làm phẳng rồi mô hình nó vẫn nhận
ra được. Nhưng nếu mà chúng ta dùng mô
hình nó có khả năng nó nhận diện cái dữ
liệu gốc ban đầu trong không gian này
nó nhận diện sẽ còn tốt hơn. Các bác cứ
tưởng tượng là bây giờ nếu không phải
nhận diện là số đi nó sẽ diện là cái đối
tượng như kiểu là xe cộ người các thứ ấ
đúng không nó phức tạp hơn thì cái việc
là có thông tin về không gian này là cái
tố nó vùng quan trọng thì các cái thuật
toán machining nó không làm được cái
điều này tại vì machining nó chỉ làm
việc với rượu dạng phẳng thôi. Đấy kiểu
có những cái feature các cái feature các
bạn tách dàn hàng ngang thì các bạn mới
làm việc được. còn nó thành cái hình
khối này nó sẽ không làm việc được đúng
không? đấy chính là cái nhược điểm của
của
các cái tám machine truyền thống nó sẽ
mất những thông tin về sptial
information thậm chí là nếu bạn nó mà là
video thì sẽ mất nó mất mất luôn cả
temporal information tức là thông thoặt
thời gian tức là spial and temporal
information về mặt không gian thô th mặt
thời gian cái toán machining nó không
giữ được cái điều đấy tại vì là muốn đưa
vào trong mô hình là chúng ta phải làm
phẳng rồi thì đấy là cái nhược điểm của
cái thuật toán trong machin
again cái bài toán này nó vẫn chạy được.
Vì sao? Tại vì rượu nó đơn giản quá.
Nhưng mà khi mà các bạn gặp những bộ
rượu khác phức tập hơn, các bạn thấy là
cái performance m nó sẽ drop rất là
mạnh. Được chưa? Đấy là lý do mà vì sao
mà trong thực tế ấ người ta chỉ dùng các
cái toán trong machine truyền thống này
để giải quyết các cái bộ dữ liệu dạng
bảng thôi, dạng file Excel, dạng file
JSV ấy, Excel với cả CSV ấy thì người ta
dùng machin truyền thống. Tại vì ngay
ban đầu cái rượu nó là mảng hai chiều
rồi, số ba sample bao nhiêu cột rồi đúng
không? Thế còn với dạng text trong bảng
NLP hoặc là trong hoặc là ảnh trong
compation ấy, một vài bài toán đơn giản
thì cố dùng thì cũng được nhưng mà nhìn
chung là cái performance nó sẽ không
cao. Sau này các bạn học về deing các
bạn sẽ biết là à trong deing người ta có
những cái kiến trúc mạng nonon, mạng non
tích chập để giúp tôi có thể làm sao tôi
có thể tôi xử lý được những cái bộ rượu
này mà tôi không cần phải làm phẳng. Khi
tôi không cần phải làm phẳng tôi sẽ giữ
được thông tin về mặt không gian và
thông tin về mặt thời gian từ dữ liệu.
Và điều này nó sẽ hữu ích cho mô hình
trong quá trình mô hình nó đưa dự đoán.
Được chưa? Thì ở đây chúng ta dùng thử
chúng ta biết là à cố thì vẫn được nhưng
trong thực tế sẽ không ai dùng machining
để làm những bài toán như này. Được
chưa?
Rồi. Ok. Có nào câu hỏi gì không?
Ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Thấy nhá. Không có rất là ngắn đúng
không? Rất là đơn giản nhưng mà người ta
sẽ không dùng đâu. Ta sẽ không dùng kiểu
này đâu. Được chưa? Ta sẽ dùng kiểu
khác. người ta dùng những cái mạng
neuron, mạng neuron tích chập để người
ta giải quyết chứ người ta không người
ta dùng truyền thống cả. Được chưa? Các
bạn sẽ chỉ g thấy các bạn sẽ chỉ thấy
gặp dùng h truyền thống để giải quyết
được cái bài toán này trong những cái
khóa học thôi. Thực tế không ai người ta
dùng thế này cả. Ừ. À khi nào c data
augmentation? Data augmentation hay là
tăng cường dữ liệu có nghĩa là gì? Data
augmentation có nghĩa là tôi muốn tạo ra
thêm nhiều dữ liệu để mô hình nó có thể
học một cách đa dạng hơn đúng không?
Giống kiểu các bạn tạo ra thêm đề bài để
các bạn học. Đấy. Được chưa? Thì nhìn
chung là data người ta sẽ luôn luôn muốn
áp dụng. Bao giờ người ta muốn áp dụng
data vì sao? Thì giúp cho cái sự đa dạng
của dữ liệu nó nó tốt hơn. Ví dụ với ảnh
nhá. Ví dụ với ảnh đi. Tăng cường dữ
liệu có nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là có cái
ảnh gốc này. Các bạn xoay nó một tí. Các
bạn lật trái phải trái phải phải trái,
các bạn zoom in, zoom out một chút, các
bạn close một chút, các bạn translate
một chút, các bạn biến đổi độ sáng, độ
tương phản, độ nhòe, độ bão hòa một
chút. Đấy là các bạn đã thay đổi, các
bạn đã data augmentation rồi. Được chưa?
Lúc nào người ta cũng sẽ muốn dùng. Tại
vì chúng ta muốn mùi nó tiếp xúc với dữ
liệu một cách nó đa dạng hơn. Được chưa?
Ok.
À không hẳng
ờ
overing ấy là gì? Là tôi về vật bản chất
là tôi tạo ra dữ liệu mới. Còn data là
gì? Là tôi tạo ra cái biến thể của cái
dữ liệu cũ.
Tức là gì? Tức là cùng cái ảnh này nhá.
Cùng cái ảnh này mình cùng cái ảnh này
khi mình huấn luyện mô hình mình sẽ đưa
nó vào mô hình rất nhiều lần. Nhưng mà
mình mình muốn là gì? Mỗi lần nữa vào mô
hình nó sẽ phải khác đi một tí. Lần này
ảnh trông nhày là xong ảnh nó sẽ tối hơn
một tí. Ảnh nữa lần nữa ảnh nó sẽ bị
xoay một tí. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Thế còn
over singing là nó sẽ tạo ra rượu mới
nguyên. Rượu coi như là rượu hai sle nó
là hai cái sle tách biệt nhau. Đấy tất
nhiên về mặt ý nghĩa nó sẽ đều giúp cho
mô hình có thể nhìn rượu đa dạng hơn.
Nhưng mà về bản chất thì nó khác nhau mà
làm gì? Một ông là tạo ra cái bản mới,
một ông là tạo ra cái biến thể cho cái
bản cũ.
Over sampling ấy là nó sẽ tạo ra một cái
instance mới bên cạnh cái instance cũ.
Còn data là gì? Chỉ là mỗi lần các bạn
đưa vào các bạn biến đổi trên cái ảnh
đấy thôi. Các bạn không tạo ra một cái
ảnh mới. Tức là các bạn không cho nó
thành một cái xem nó không cho nó thành
một cái thực thể mới tách biệt hoàn toàn
mà tôi chỉ tôi biến đổi cái ảnh này để
tôi đưa vào trong mô hình thôi.
Trong giai đoạn tiền xử lý mà mình chỉ
có tập đặc trưng X chưa có nhãn Y. Ngoài
việc dùng mấy hàm chckch cơ bản bán đáp
thực tế có nghiên cứu hay trích nào để
soát nhanh xem khoanh vùng các cái mẫu
bị trùng lặp hoặc cần giống nhau xử rượu
bị huyết ơ trùng lập thì dễ mà các bạn
trùng lặp các bạn so sánh các tất cả cái
giá giá trị mà giống nhau y hệt thì là
trùng lạp thôi trong pandas ấy nó có cái
hàm remove duplicate ấy nó không d bạn
không phải remove drop dlicate ấy rất là
dễ thôi trùng lặp tức là hai giống y
hiệt nhau cái đấy thì dễ thôi mà đúng
không à đây này một cái hàm à
tên hàm
Drop duplicate đây này.
Này drop duplicate này rất là dễ thôi.
Được chưa? Drop nan thì cũng dễ luôn.
Drop nan thì có cho có cái hàm drop nan
mà. Drop na này. Drop na này. Đấy drop
nan này. Được chưa? Rất là dậy đúng
không? Nhưng mà tất nhiên là các bạn dự
bị khuyết nó có hai kiểu xử lý đó. Một
là các bạn drop nếu mà nó ít quá nó ít
cái ô bị bị khuyết quá thì các bạn drop
nó cho nó dễ. Còn không các bạn phải tí
cách các bạn điền vào được chưa?
Chúng ta dùng cái simple imputer đấy.
Simple imputter của Sơn đấy. Đúng không?
N chúng ta học rồi
đấy. Mong là chúng ta học rồi. Được
chưa?
Rồi. B nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Thế tức là nói về bản dữ liệu nhá. Khi
các bạn làm trong cái mảng AI này, trong
mảng AItion ấy, các bạn sẽ gặp
ba kiểu dữ liệu phổ biến nhất. Một là dữ
liệu dạng bảng Excel với CSV ấy. Thì với
rượu dạ bảng người ta sẽ thường người ta
sẽ thông thường người ta sẽ dùng ming
truyền thống. Có thể các bạn nếu các bạn
có rất nhiều dữ liệu chúng ta có thể cân
nhắc thì dùng deep learning. Thế còn hai
cái loại tiếp theo là dữ liệu dạng văn
bản cho cái mảngp và ảnh hoặc là video
trong mảng compation thì thường ta sẽ
dùng kiến trúc neuron. Ví dụ như là
thêm một tí nhá. Ví dụ dự ảnh này ta
thường ta sẽ dùng CNN hay là
convolutional new network mạng n nó tích
chập. Thì với CNN ấy các bạn sẽ không
bao giờ các bạn phải làm phẳng sữa đồ
vào. Giữa đồ vào nó có là ảnh thậ nó là
video các bạn cũng sẽ không các bạn phải
làm phẳng nó kiểu gì n thì nó cũng sẽ mô
hình CN nó cũng sẽ tiêu hóa được. Được
chưa? Và làm nhờ như vậy nó sẽ bảo toàn
được cái thông tin mặt không gian của dữ
liệu. Thế còn với bảng NLP á cái hồi
trước 2017 2018 ấy thì người ta dùng
kiến trúc gọi là recurrent new network
hay là mạng non hồi quy. Thế nhưng mà
sau 2017 2018 thì người ta không còn
dùng rec new network nữa rồi. Người ta
dùng
transformer đúng không? Transformer và
bây giờ chúng ta dùng các cái mô hình
ngôn ngữ lớn. Đấy thì với những cái mô
hình như vậy bất kể là convolutional New
Network hay là recur new network hay là
Transformer hay là LM ấy thì chúng nó
đều
giúp cái việc là chúng ta có thể tiếp
nhận cái rượu đồ vào nó tốt hơn. Chúng
ta không phải là phẳng, chúng ta không
cần phải phá cái tính cấu trúc của dữ
liệu. Được chưa?
Chú ý nhá, nói là như vậy nhưng mà khi
mà người ta gọi tên ấy, người ta sẽ gọi
những cái rượu bảng ấy, cái file CSV,
file Excel ấ người ta sẽ gọi đây là rượu
có cấu trúc, structure data. Thế còn ảnh
với cả văn bản ta gọi là rượu phi cấu
trúc được chưa? Unstructure data nhá.
Ok. Ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Có câu hỏi gì không? Thế thôi đúng
không? Com chúng ta đi qua một chút
thôi. Tức là gì? Chúng ta biết là à tôi
dùng maching thì tôi cũng giải quyết
được một vài bài toán đơn giản đấy. Đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà thường ta sẽ không
dùng cách này. Được chưa?
Rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Khi chúng ta nghỉ giả lao 5 phút các bạn
nhá. Xong chúng ta vào chúng ta quay lại
tiếp về cái PCA nhá.
Nào các bạn có câu hỏi gì bạn cứ hỏi
nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi nhá.
Đọc bá một tí.
nhận diện.
Nhận diện của em thì tức là cái output
đầu ra thì em muốn là mô hình nó chỉ ra
là đây là đây là di tích văn hóa hay là
em phải chỉ ra cụ thể là đây là di tích
văn hóa gì? à tên di sản á à
sẽ k em sẽ cần với mỗi một cái di sản em
sẽ cần khoảng
5 cho đến 10 à phi vật thể á
phi vật thể tức là kiểu ca trù các thứ á
ui giời
Ơ thế nhưng mà thế input đầu vào nó là
cái gì?
Nhận diện di sản vi vật thể.
Từ mình sẽ gọi xem ca là cái gì đã. Từ
từ mình mình a chị
ờ
thú thật nhá. Thú thật là à ờ thú thật
là nếu mà muốn giả được cái bài toán này
ấy thì đầu tiên là phải có cái hiểu biết
về cái mảng này đã. Tức là hiểu biết về
à các cái di sản văn hóa phi vật thể. T
thật là mình cũng không rõ ca trù về
những cái kiểu khác nó khác gì nhau. Tôi
thật là bây giờ mấy cái kiểu ngồi dưới
chiếu này mình cũng không biết là phân
biệt được chúng với nhau như nào. Ờ
thế nhưng nếu mà kiểu này thì có lẽ là
có lẽ là mỗi với mỗi một cái loại hình
em có thể em sẽ cần khoảng anh nghĩ cũng
không nhiều đâu. Tại vì đây là
ó lẽ là với mỗ cái loại thì mà mình có
khoảng
vài chục thì ok.
vài chục khoảng vài chục game nó cũng
không cần quá nhiều tại vì đây không
phải là bài toán
đây sẽ là đây không phải là bài toán
image classification đây là bài toán
image matching tức là em sẽ có một cái
database em có rất nhiều ảnh ví dụ là
mỗi một cái loại hình em sẽ có khoảng
năm năm ảnh 10 ảnh đi. Bây giờ em có một
cái ảnh mới phải xem là cái độ tương
đồng giữa ảnh mới với ảnh cũ này nó như
nào. Nó không phải là phân loạ nó sẽ là
matching. Nó giống kiểu là disable ấy.
Thế nhưng mà đúng là cái mảng này thì
muốn làm thì phải có hiểu biết về cái
hình đấy mình sẽ biết là cái ảnh nó tốt
ảnh nó không. Thế còn nếu không biết thì
nó sẽ hơi khó đấy. Nhưng mà đấy nó chung
là image maching. Tức là mình trong cơ
sở dữ liệu mình có ví dụ mỗi loại hình
có 10
cái ảnh đi đúng không? Mình mình sẽ xem
là cái ảnh mới của mình nó có tương đồng
như thế này không. Nhưng mà đấy anh cũng
không rõ là cái ca trù v mấy tại vì anh
thấy là có nhiều cái loại hình mà nó
cũng người ta cũng ngồi xuống đất người
ta có mấy ông đánh đàn đánh đánh các thứ
này mình cũng không rõ là nó có khác gì
mấy cái kia không tại vì có thể là cùng
ngồi xuống dưới đất nhưng mà cái này gọi
là ca trù cái kia thì gọi là cái gì đấy
đúng không?
Có chứ. đồ án về chatbot về văn h em cửa
sổ trò chuyện tức là muốn câu sau nói
memory cấu trước đúng không? Thế bây giờ
những cái memory cấu trước em có thể
dùng cái một một cái gọi là một cái
buffer một cái bộ nhớ đệm đúng không?
Khi mà em cho in khi mà khi mà cho những
câu mới em sẽ gắn cả cái history. Ví dụ
cửa sổ Windows là trong 5 hoặc là 10 câu
gần đây nhá đúng không? Để mô hình nó sẽ
phán đoán xem là liệu cái history nó có
cần thiết hay không đúng không? Nó chỉ
là đơn giản nó là một cái mảng tôi gắn
thêm vào thôi. Thấy chưa? Khi mà con
chatbox của em nó trả lời đúng nó sẽ có
cái context. Context này thì vừa là từ
những cái trang của tôi và từ và nó vừa
là cái cái từ cái những cái câu hỏi câu
trả lời trước đúng không? Nó sẽ có hai
nguồn. một nguồn trăng một nguồn à
previous message chưa?
Giống cái của Vin hôm nọ á giống cái
hack thần giống cái của Vin hôm nọ á.
Ừ.
Đợt này đợt này bên ngoại thương họ cũng
đang tổ chức một cái cuộc thi to phết
đấy các bạn. Ừ thật đây đây là thần anh
thân tức là nó đều là cuộc thi đúng
không? Ừ nó nó đều là cuộc thi đúng
không? Cái kia về data sa data ai nó
cũng nó về các cái mô hình mà đúng
không?
Thú thật là mình trước giờ từ bé giờ
mình chưa giờ mình đi theo cuộc thi bao
giờ tại vì cái thời ngày xưa của mình có
như cuộc thi nó chưa có phổ biến. Nhưng
mà khi có cuộc thi này các bạn nên có
một cái team nó sẽ tốt hơn hoặc các bạn
thi mình nó sẽ hơi khó tại vì một team
các bạn phải phân công việc các thứ và
thật ra cuộc thi này muốn để giải cao
các bạn sẽ phải khá là default tức là
khá phải đặt thời gian vào nó đấy chứ
không phải là chỉ tại vì các bạn sẽ phải
cần thử nghiệm rất là nhiều. Nhiều khi
mình là giám khảo có khi mà bảo mình làm
mô hình, có khi mình không có thời gian
mình làm không tốt bằng các bạn đâu.
Thì nếu mà các bạn thứ nhất các bạn phải
có một cái team, thứ hai là ờ thông
thường ấy các cái các cái team mà họ hay
được cái giải cao ấy thì họ sẽ phải phất
nhiều giải pháp với nhau. Tất những giải
pháp nó không theo bài đâu. Nó không
theo bài. Nó không phải là các bạn chỉ
chạy ờ random fred các bạn chọn các bạn
chọn linear reion không phải như vậy.
hay là về di link không phải các bạn chỉ
chạy một cái mạng CNN các bạn chạy mô
hình restnet hoặc các bạn chạy các bạn
chạy efficent net là xong nó sẽ không
phải như vậy nó sẽ bao gồm rất nhiều cái
bước khác nhau và những cái bước này
thường nó sẽ yêu cầu cái khả năng gọi là
khả năng sáng tạ tại vì là những cái thứ
mà theo bài ấy thì ông nào chả làm được
đúng không theo bài thì ông nào mà chả
làm được đấ
ờ có một cái yếu tố mà mình không thích
lắm về các cái cuộc thi là gì là các cái
cuộc thi ấy tất nhiên là đấy cũng phải
lỗi của họ tại vì là họ cũng không thể
làm gì khác có một cái điểm mình không
thích ở các cái cuộc thi về AI hackon
các thứ chẳng hạn ấy tại vì là nó chỉ
đánh giá được một cái khía gạch của sản
phẩm thôi. Tức là gì? Ví dụ là độ thường
là độ chính xác đúng không? Cái team nào
ra cái độ chính xác nó càng cao thì càng
tốt. Họ không đánh giá những cái việc là
liên quan đến triển khai. Tức là ờ mô
hình của tôi tốt nhưng mà tôi lại chiếm
tài nguyên lớn. Tôi phải chạy tốn nhiều
tài nguyên đúng không? Rồi chạy nó lâu.
Thường các cái cuộc thi nó không cân
chắc cái điều đấy. Mà trong khi đây cái
điều mà cái khi mà các bạn đi làm ở công
ty thực tế nó rất là quan trọng.
Hai cái mô hình sát tương đương nhau
nhưng một ông chạy nhanh gấp đôi ông kia
từ tụt ít thành nguyên bằng một nửa ông
kia thế là mô hình nó đã lợi hơn rất là
nhiều rồi đúng không?
Cái hôm mình làm cuộc thi ấy thì các cái
đội ấy tức là họ submit cái giải pháp
lên trên KG và nó chấm điểm trên với cái
bộ test trên đấy. Bản thân mình mình còn
chưa được nhìn code của các cái đội. Họ
chỉ có cái hôm họ trình bày giải pháp và
mình Q&A thôi. Thật ra nó đáng nhẽ là
phải được đáng nhẽ là phải được phải
phải chấm ở cái sản phẩm của họ cái cái
source code của họ để xem là họ chỉ
khách nào. Tại vì có thể là gì? Có thể
là một cái team chọn dùng mô hình đơn
giản họ được cái Aquosi 80%. Một cái một
một cái team họ dùng họ dùng đủ cái mô
hình họ được 82% lên được 2% nhưng mà họ
lại phải tốn th ngên gấp hết bên kia cả
trăm lần thì nó trong thực tế là đây đổi
phải cân nhắc nhưng mà do là giám khảo
không ai đ biết sóc cod cả chỉ nghe họ
trình bày thôi và thật ra nhiều khi
trình bày nó liên quan đến cái việc là
nhiều khi cái mô hình mình nó làm tốt
nhưng mà cái khả năng diễn đạn nó không
tốt thì ban giám khảo sẽ đánh giá thấp
hơn và ngược lại. Nhưng mà đây là tham
dã cuộc thi nó phải chấp nhận như vậy.
cu thi mà ờ có những cuộc thi họ làm ví
dụ ở bên nước ngoài họ làm rất là cẩn
thận tức là sẽ phải có cả đoạn test code
xem có thực sự code nó chạy không nhưng
mà thật ra với cái thời ngày xưa thì cái
việc đấy còn có ý nghĩa cho bây giờ các
bạn dùng AI các bạn code thì gần như là
mô hình nào nó cũng sẽ chạy được thôi.
Đấ
thôi tiếp nhá. Quay lại cái chính chúng
ta nh cái gì đây?
Không phải mạng cộ thi của Vin họ cũng
không đâu. Team nào tự lo nhưng mà có
những cuộc thi họ sao họ hỗ trợ. Có cuộc
thi họ hỗ trợ.
Ờ
quay lại nhá. Đã nói giờ chúng ta đã nói
về PCA đúng không? Mình xem xem là nói
bây giờ nhá. Bây giờ nói về mình sẽ nói
các bạn về từng bước về PCA. Thế nhưng
mà trước khi nói về từng bước này chúng
ta sẽ phải có một vài những cái
khái niệm đi trước. Cả lớp cho mình hỏi
nhá.
Các bạn ở đây có bạn nào các bạn đã từng
học môn a môn
môn đại số rồi nào các bạn đã từng được
học môn đại số trước đây cho mình số 1
bạn nào các bạn chưa từng học bao giờ
cho mình số 0. Đại số hoặc là đại số
tuyến tính tùy trường gọi. Có trường
người ta gọi là môn đại số, có trường
gọi môn đại số tuyến tính
nhá. Ok.
Ấn hết cả lớp này.
Trong môn đại số và trong môn đại số
tuyến tính nó có hai cái khái niệm được
gọi là
vector và value. Đúng không? Bạn nào các
bạn từng nghe hai khái niệm chưa? Again
value và vector. Quừng nghe được hai
khái niệm này bao giờ chưa?
I value và I vector. Nghe chưa? Nghe rồi
đúng không? Ừ. Trị riêng và vecơ riêng.
Thế mà nó để phân tích cái từ các bạn
nhá.
Có bạn nào biết cái từ nghĩa là gì
không? I get nghĩa là gì? I nhìn nó hơi
lạ đúng không? Nó lạ tại vì là nó không
phải là từ tiếng Anh, nó là từ tiếng
Đức.
Igen nghĩa là của sở hữu. Tức là này nó
giống cái từ này trong tiếng Anh ấ nó
dùng cái từ này nó tự dống từ
nhá.
Nó
xấp xỉ cái từ là
chưa em sẽ ôn này. Sở hữu của chưa? Sở
hữu của thế
ế các bạn có value và vectơ là trị riêng
và vectơ riêng. Thế thôi. Easy được
chưa?
Thế thì à
thế thì em lưu về vectơ có ý nghĩa gì
thì các bạn nhìn nhá. Đây mình sẽ mở
mình dùng slide của lớp toán. Toán này
lâu lắm rồi mình không có dạy.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Các bạn đều môn đại số
rồi. Trong môn đại số cái việc phép nhân
ma trận các bạn đều quen đúng không?
Nhân hai ma trận với nhau đúng không? Ở
đây là phép nhân giữa một ma trận và một
vectơ. Nhưng vecơ các bạn cũng có thể
hiểu nó là một cái ma trận cột như này.
Được chưa? Ở đây là tôi đang muốn nhân
cái ma trận A với cái ma trận X.
Ma trận A có kích thước là 3 x 3. Ma
trận X có kích thước là 3 x 1. Các bạn
cho mình hỏi nhá. Trong môn đại số, điều
kiện để tôi có thể nhân được ma trận A
với ma trận B điều kiện tiên quyết là
gì? Hai ma trận mà muốn nhân được với
nhau điều kiện là gì?
Ma trận A nhân với ma trận B. À số cột
của A phải bằng số hàng của B. Số cột
của ma trận trước phải bằng số hàng của
ma trận sau. Đúng không? Nó không giống
như kiểu là nó không phải là giống kiểu
nhân trong 5 tai. Nhân trong 5 tai là
hai trận kích thước phải bằng nhau hoặc
là nó có quy tắc nào đấy. Nhưng trong
đại số tuyến tính ấy một hai bạn nhận
rất là đơn giản. Số cột của ông đầu bằng
số hàng của ông hai. Các bạn nhìn đây
ông đầu nó có ba cột ông hai nó có ba
hàng đúng không? Ba cột ba hàng nhân rất
là dễ được chưa?
Thế thì
phác nhân thì rất là dễ thôi đúng không?
Nhân cứ lấy từng hàng của ông đầu nhân
với từng cột của ông ha. Xong này. Được
chưa? Đây nhân này không không ai có vấn
đề gì đúng không?
Thế các bạn nhìn này, cái phép nhân ma
trận, cái phép nhân một ma trận với một
vecơ như này ấy, đúng không? Mặc dù tôi
hiểu là m vecơ đây tôi cũng hiểu nó là
một cái ma trận đặc biệt đúng không? Nó
chỉ có một cột thôi đúng không? Phép
nhân này nó có ý nghĩa gì?
Cái phép như này ấy, cái output của tôi
nó cũng sẽ là một cái vecơ hoặc là một
cái ma trận cột giống với cái input x
này. Thế thì về mặt bản chất của phép
nhân giữa một ma trận vuông, ví dụ đây
là ma trận vuông kích thước 3 x 3 với
một cái vecơ có độ dài là 3 phần tử là
khi mà tôi nhân một cái ma trận với một
vectơ này là tôi đang thực hiện một cái
phép biến đổi để tôi áp dụng lên cái
vectơ input đầu vào x này. Đúng không?
Tôi vecơ đầu hào tôi là x. Tôi áp dụng
một cái phép biến đổi nào đấy lên cái
vecơ này để ta để tôi ra được cái vecơ
output đầu ra là ax. Được chưa? Vơ đầu
ra là ax như này
thì nó cũng tương đương việc là gì? Là
các bạn giống như là các bạn dùng có hàm
y = f(x) thôi đúng không? Hàm y = f(x)
là gì? Là tôi có cái input x đầu vào tôi
qua một cái phép biến đổi f nó ánh xài
cái x này ra cái output là y đúng không?
Thì x ở đây chính là cái x này. Còn y ở
đây chính là cái ax đây. Đúng không? Tức
là gì? Về mặt bản chất là khi tôi áp
dụng phép nhân ma trận vuông với một
vecơ có cùng số chiều ờ cùng số cô số
hàng với cái ma trận đấy là tôi đang áp
dụng một cái phép biến đổi được thể hiện
bởi cái ma trận a này lên cái vectơ x
của tôi và tôi ra đốt đầu ra nó như thế
này. Được chưa?
Thì nhìn chung ấy phép biến đổi này nó
sẽ nó sẽ biến đổi cái giá trị của vectơ
đi. Vectơ ban đầu có thể là 0 5 4 nhân
xong nó thể thành là -1 2 3 kiểu kiểu
như vậy đúng không? Tức là nhìn chung
khi các bạn áp dụng một cái phép biến
đổi lên một cái vecơ thì vectơ output nó
sẽ thay đổi đi. Được chưa? Ngày xưa á
hồi chúng ta học cấp ba chúng ta bắt đầu
làm quen với vecơ.
Một cái vecơ ấy được đặc trưng bởi hai
đại lượng là cái gì các bạn nhở? Một
vecơ bất kỳ được đặc trưng bởi hai đại
lượng là cái gì?
Có bạn nào còn nhớ không? Một vecơ bất
kỳ được đặc trưng bởi hai đại lượng là
à
chiều và độ lớn đúng không? Hướng. Đúng
rồi. Hướng và độ lớn đúng không?
Chiều hay là hướng khác gì phương? Chiều
là là tôi chỉ ra cái chiều như thế này
đúng không? Đây này. Chiều là như này
đây.
Đây như này. Đây chiều như này. Đấy.
Chiều như này. Thế còn phương là cái gì?
Phương là cái đường thẳng đi qua nó đúng
không? Hai vecơ cùng phương thì có thể
là cùng chiều cùng hướng đấy. Hoặc là
khác chiều đúng không? Đấy khác biệt
đúng không? một vectơ được được đặc đặc
trưng bởi bởi bởi hướng và độ dài chứ nó
không đ được được nó không được đặc
trưng bởi cái điểm đầu hay là điểm kết
thúc. Tại vì sao? Đây là vectơ 0. Đây là
vectơ 22 đây cũng là vectơ 22. Các bạn
sẽ có vô số vecơ như vậy đúng không? Một
vecơ được đại diện bởi hướng và độ lớn.
Độ lớn chính là hay ngày xưa chúng ta
hay gọi là giá của vecơ đấy. Đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà nó không được đại diện bởi
cái gốc. Gốc đập vào đâu cũng được. Tôi
tịnh tiến đây về đây cũng thoải mái đúng
không? Đấy.
Thế thì quay lại đây chúng ta nó nói về
cái việc là chúng ta áp dụng phép nhân
ma trận để cho tôi biến đổi vecơ này.
Thì các bạn nhìn này, nhìn chung á, nhìn
chung khi mà tôi áp dụng, ví dụ đây là
tôi trong không gian hai chiều đi đúng
không? Nhìn chung ấy khi mà tôi áp dụng
một cái phép nhân ma trận lên những cái
vecơ ấy là tôi đang biến đổi cái vecơ
này. Được chưa? Ví dụ đây trong không
gian của tôi, trong không gian hai chiều
tôi có rất nhiều vecơ. Cái vectơ của tôi
sẽ có gốc là gốc tọa độ và
cái đỉnh à cái cái cái end point của
vecơ là những cái điểm màu xanh. Được
chưa? Mình sẽ không nối cái điểm gốc tọa
độ với điểm màu xanh này. Các bạn tưởng
tượng là gì? Vectơ sẽ nối có những vectơ
đơn giản tôi nối từ gốc tọa độ đến cái
điểm màu xanh này. Được chưa? Thế thì
tôi có cái ma trận như này. Cái ma trận
tôi là có đường chéo chính là 1 + delta
và 1. Còn đứa chéo phụ là bằng 0 này.
Được delta thường nó số lớn hơn 0. Ví dụ
đây là del8 bằng 0,5. Thì các bạn nhìn
này, khi mà tôi áp khi mà tôi
lấy tất cả cái vecơ của tôi được đại
diện bởi các cái đường nối từ gốc đến
các cái điểm màu xanh ấy, tôi thiện phép
nhân ma trận với cái ma trận S này. S đi
trước, vectơ đi sau nhá, đúng không? Thì
nhìn chung ấy nhìn chung là cái vecơ
output và vectơ input ấy chúng nó sẽ
khác nhau cả về phương và cả về và cả về
độ lớn đúng không? Phương là như vậy nói
phương nó có thể là hai ông cùng phương
có thể là cùng chiều hoặc ngược chiều đ
phương là cái đường thẳng đi qua cái
vecơ được chưa? Thế thì khi mà chúng ta
với cái ma trận như này, ma trận S này
ấy, khi tôi áp dụng cái phép biến đổi
được thể hiện cái ma trận S này, ma trận
S1 này với các cái vecơ của tôi thì nhìn
chung là cái vectơ output so với các cái
vecơ input ấ chúng nó sẽ thay đổi cả về
cả về độ lớn cũng như là phương.
Tuy nhiên
đối với cái ma trận S1 này, đối với mỗi
một cái ma trận mà trong cụ thể trường
này là ma trận S1 này, nó sẽ có những
cái vecơ đặc biệt, cái vecơ input đặc
biệt, vecơ mà nối từ gấp đến điểm màu
xanh ấy có những vectơ đặc biệt. Đặc
biệt đấy là gì? Đặc biệt là những cái
vecơ này sau khi được áp dụng cái phép
biến đổi được thể hiện qua cái ma trận S
này ấy thì cái vectơ output ấy độ lớn
thay đổi hay không thì không biết nhưng
về phương nó không đổi. Tức là phương
của vectơ input và phương của vectơ
output chúng nó không đổi.
Mặc dù hầu hết các vecơ đều đổi. Các bạn
nhìn này ví dụ nhá. Đúng không? Các bạn
nối từ gốc này đến cái vecơ màu xanh này
từ gốc đến vectơ màu đỏ đúng không? Thì
rõ ràng là gì? là vectơ input, vectơ
output khác nhau cả về mặt độ lớn cũng
như là về mặt phương rồi. Thế nhưng có
những cái điểm màu xanh mà khi bạn nối
cái gốc tọa độ với điểm xanh đấy thành
với vecơ thì nó sẽ là những cái vecơ đặc
biệt mà vectơ output so với input nó
không bị thay đổi về mặt phương. Bạn nào
chỉ cho mình là những cái điểm màu xanh
nó nằm ở đâu trong cái không gian này
thì nó sẽ là những cái vecơ đặc biệt như
thế.
Những cái vecơ như thế nào là những cái
vecơ đặc biệt? À đúng nắm chục Ox là 1
đúng không? Tất cả những cái điểm màu
xanh à ở đây và đây mình sẽ ngoại trừ
gốc tọa độ nhá. Những cái điểm màu xanh
tại vì điểm màu xanh mà trùng với gốc
tọa độ nó thành vectơ 0 rồi mình ở đây
mình loại trừ vectơ 0 nhá đúng không?
Những cái điểm màu xanh nào không trùng
gốc tọa độ mà tôi sẽ đảm bảo là vectơ
output về input cùng phương. Thứ nhất là
các cái mình làm gì đã có vecor đâu. Làm
gì biết vector nó là cái gì đâu đúng
không? Ở đây mình chưa nói gì đến vector
value cả. Đúng rồi. Một là gì? Những cái
điểm màu xanh mà nằm trên trục Ox ấy thì
chúng ta sẽ đảm bảo là input và output
độ lớn không nói nhưng về phương nó
trùng nhau cùng phương.
Ngoài ra còn cái gì nữa? Ngoài những
điểm trên trục hoành còn cái gì nữa? Còn
những điểm nào nữa?
Còn điểm nào nữa các bạn?
Có ai nhìn ra nữa không? Một là các bạn
nhìn vào hình, hai là các bạn nhìn vào
công thức. Nhìn vào công thức cũng ra.
Đúng rồi. Cả những điểm nào trên trục OY
nữa. Tất cả các cái điểm nằm trên trục
Ox và tất cả những điểm nằm trên trục OY
ấ là nó sẽ tạo ra những cái vecơ đặc
biệt. Những vecơ đặc biệt này nó sẽ giúp
cho là
không phải giúp cho mà sau phép nhân ma
trận này ấ cái vectơ output ấ nó sẽ
không bị thay đổi về mặt
phương so với input. Được chưa? Nhưng
các bạn chú ý này, những cái vectơ đặc
biệt này không phải ma trận nào nó cũng
thế. Với ma trận S1 thì những cái vecơ
nằm trên trục hoành và những vectơ nằm
trên trục tung là những cái vecơ đặc
biệt như vậy. Nhưng mà nó chỉ đặc biệt
đối với ma trận S1 này thôi. Đối với cái
ma trận khác thì
Đối với ma trận khác thì nó sẽ nó sẽ có
những cái vecơ khác. Được chưa? Thế bây
giờ đấy là nói về mặt tính chất. Thế bây
giờ nói về mặt hình học đi.
Vì sao chúng ta lại nói về cái phép nhân
này? Tại vì đây chính là cái phép mà
người ta giãn ảnh, resize cái ảnh. Đấy,
các bạn tưởng tượng một cái ảnh như này,
một cái ảnh vậy mà mình vừa
đây. Một cái ảnh như này. Được chưa? Một
cái ảnh như này. Bây giờ, bây giờ tôi
muốn là chiều cao thì không đổi nhưng mà
chiều ngang thì tăng lên. Chiều ngang
tăng gấp đôi, chiều cao giữ nguyên. Được
chưa? Tôi muốn lần như vậy thì chúng ta
sẽ gọi thư viện thôi. Tất nhiên là khi
các bạn trong thực tế các bạn lập trình
các bạn sẽ dùng thư viện thôi. Các bạn
dùng open CV các bạn dùng thư viện open
CV của Python chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy
đúng không? Các bạn sẽ dùng cái hàm
resize chiều cao giữ nghiên, chiều ngang
nó tăng gấp đôi thì các bạn sẽ kéo ra
đúng không? Thế nhưng mà về mặt bản chất
các bạn dùng thư viện là như vậy nhưng
mà ở phía sau ấy là người ta dùng cái ma
trận phép nhân ma trận như thế này. Được
chưa? Các cái điện tọa độ gốc ban đầu là
x1 x2. Tọa độ sau khi các bạn biến đổi
là 1 + delta x1 với x2 này. Những cái
pixel ở dương chúng ta sẽ nội suy người
ta điền vào được chưa? Tức là khi chúng
ta dùng các cái thư viện để biến đổi ảnh
thì thật ra về mặt bản chất phía sau ấy
là người ta dùng những cái phép nhân ma
trận. Đấy được chưa? Đấy đây là một cái
được chưa? Và nhớ là như mình vừa nói
rồi. Những cái vecơ nằm ra trong trục
hoành với trục tung ấy nó chỉ là vectơ
đặc biệt với cái ma trận F1 này thôi.
Được chưa? Mặt trận F1 nó như này nó sẽ
có cái tác dụng nó dãn ảnh theo chiều
ngang.
Thế đổi lại nếu mà một cột delta không
phải là ở vị trí đầu tiên mà vị trí cuối
cùng này thì nó cũng là giãn ảnh nhưng
mà giãn theo chiều dọc. Được chưa? Và
cũng tương tự trường hợp vừa rồi thì
chúng ta cũng sẽ có những cái vecơ đặc
biệt là những vecơ nằm dọc theo trục
hoành và vectơ dọc theo trục tung đúng
không? Thì input và output giá
của vecơ hay là độ dài thay đổi hay
không thì không biết nhưng mà ít nhất là
cái phường nó giống nhau. Được chưa? Này
nhiều khi người ta muốn resiz ảnh người
ta muốn cái ảnh nó về một kích thc một
kích thước chuẩn thôi thì người ta giãn.
Ví dụ ảnh người ta là kích thước ở vuông
ảnh bạn nó kích thước nó hình chữ nằm
dọc thì bạn phải giãn nó ra kiểu như vậy
chưa? Trong compion nó sẽ làm rất là
nhiều được chưa? Giãn này vừa rồi là
giãn theo chiều dọc giãn theo chiều à
giãn theo chiều ngang giãn theo chiều
dọc bây giờ tôi sẽ giãn theo cả hai phía
đúng không? Bây giờ là giãn được cả hai
phía. Thì đây các bạn nhìn đây, công
thức thì ở bên phải, hình minh họa ở bên
trái. Vẫn câu hỏi cũ. Trong cái ví dụ
cái ma trận S1S nó như thế này thì các
bạn cho mình hỏi những vecơ đặc biệt là
vecơ nào? Những vecơ nào thì đảm bảo là
vectơ input và output? Tức là output sau
khi nhân ma trận xong thì input và
output cùng phương với nhau.
Các bạn nhìn vào ông nào cũng được, các
bạn nhìn vào công thức cũng được, nhìn
vào ảnh cũng được. Ông nào đảm bảo cái
yếu tố là input output.
nhá.
À đúng rồi. Mọi vectơ đúng không? Nhìn
đây này. Input là x1 x2 output là 1 +
delta nhân x1 + delta nhân x2. Đúng tức
là gì? Output luôn là bằng hai vectơ
cùng phương là như nào? Khi mà các bạn
có thể biểu diễn các bạn có tìm một cái
hệ số k khác 0 sao cho mà ví dụ u với v
đúng không? U với v là hai vectơ cùng
phương. Khi nào? Khi mà các bạn có thể
tìm một cái số k khác 0 sao cho mà u kv
đúng không? K mà dương thì cùng phương
cùng hướng. K mà âm thì cùng phương
ngược hướng. Đúng không? Tìm một cái hệ
số k khác 0 được. là xong đúng không?
Thế đây một cái delta khác 0 mà đúng
không? Giãn dữ liệu đây chính là phép
chúng ta resize theo cả hai chiều đấy.
Được chưa? Resign theo cả hai chiều như
này. Được chưa? Chiều nào muốn to hơn
thì các bạn tăng cái số delta lên. Chiều
nào muốn muốn resign nó nhiều hơn ví dụ
chiều cao tăng gấp hai, chiều dọc chiều
ngang tăng gấp 3 chẳng hạn. Thay đổi cái
số này đi. Được chưa?
Tiếp này. Thì bây giờ nếu mà không phải
dán dữ liệu, bây giờ là co dữ liệu thì
cũng thế đúng không? Bây giờ bình thường
là cái hệ số cái đường dào chính nó lớn
hơn 1. Bây giờ nhỏ hơn 1 thì nó co lại
thôi. Thu nhỏ lại đi. Được chưa? Tiếp
này
đây là bài toán đây là phản chữ rượu hay
người ta gọi là flip lật. Flip tức là ví
dụ đây là lật trái về phải trái được
chưa? Trái sang phải sang trái thì cái
ma trận nó sẽ như này. Nếu muốn chú muốn
lật ảnh đúng không? Cái ảnh như này
ví dụ các bạn có cái ảnh à
ví dụ đây có cái ảnh nào không nhỉ?
Như các bạn xem thử nhá. Ví dụ bình
thường cái ảnh nó như này chẳng hạn.
Ờ đâu
nhá. Bình thường bạn có cái ảnh như này
đúng không các bạn? Mà muốn lật nó rất
là dễ, các bạn dùng thư viện một phát là
xong. Team
CV2 này. Image bằng CV2 này. Mình cho
các bạn xem thử nhá.
Nhá được chưa? Image bằng cb2.
Flip
bạn xem thử nhá. Lúp gốc là như này được
chưa? Lúc các bạn flip xong là thành như
này.
Đấy. Ngược chưa? Các bạn thấy không? Lúc
các bạn dùng thư viện các bạn chỉ gọi
một hàm này thôi. Nó lật rồi đúng không?
Nhưng mà bản chất ở phía sau ấy là người
ta dự phép nhân ma trận như này. Được
chưa? Ta dùng cái ma trận có tọa độ là
có giá trị là -1001 này là người ta lật
lật được đúng không? Vectơ input là x1,
x2, output là -x1, x2. Vẫn câu hỏi cũ,
những vectơ nào là vecơ đặc biệt mà
output của nó sau khi tự phép nhân ma
trận nó không thay đổi phương so với
input?
Ông nào thì đạt đảm bảo điều này nằm
trên oy đúng
hết chưa?
Nằm trên oy nó sẽ có vô số đúng không?
Nó sẽ có vô số nhưng mà những vectơ nằm
trên oy là 1 này. Và những vectơ như nào
nữa? Vectơ
là trên Ox đúng rồi đúng không? Trên o Y
và trên Ox là những vectơ đặc biệt và
nhớ nhá những cái vectơ này nó đặc biệt
là với ma trận này chứ không phải ma
trận nào nó cũng đặc biệt như thế đâu.
Được chưa? Đúng không? Đây là phản chiếu
này theo chiều ngang, theo chiều dọc
được chưa? Theo cả hai chiều. Cái này
thì tất cả đều thỏa mãn đúng không?
Output bằng -1 input tức là output luôn
cùng phương nhưng mà ngược hướng với
input. Được chưa? Tiếp này. Đây các bạn
ví dụ mình dùng cái hàm flip này được
chưa? Khi các bạn dùng thư viện nó như
này nhưng mà về mặt bản chất là chúng ta
đang dùng phép nhân ma trận đấy. Được
chưa? Tiếp này. Phép share. Share là các
bạn giống kiểu các bạn cầm hai góc cái
ảnh các bạn kéo ra ấy. Được chưa? Thì
các bạn muốn thuện sharing thì nó sẽ như
này. Nào vẫn câu hỏi cũ. Vectơ nào là
vectơ đặc biệt các bạn?
Vectơ trong cái trường hợp ma trận như
này, vectơ nào là vectơ đặc biệt?
Những vectơ nằm ở đâu thì nó đặc biệt?
Ngoại trừ vectơ 0. Ngoại trừ vectơ 0
đúng rồi. Nhưng vectơ nằm trên ox đúng
không? Nằm trên oy có được không? Vectơ
nằm trên oy có được không? Ox thì ok
rồi. Oy có được không? Nhưng vectơ nằm
dọc theo chiều oy có được không?
Những vectơ nằm dọc theo trục OY có được
không?
Không được. Đúng rồi. Ox thì được thôi.
Được chưa? Đấy thôi. Cái các cái vectơ
đặc biệt nó đã khác đi rồi đúng không?
Tất nhiên nó vẫn có vô số nhưng mà cái
nó đã ít hơn rồi. Được chưa? Làm méo
theo theo chiều cao này. Nào cái trường
này câu này khó hơn nào. Làm méo theo
đúng không?
Làm méo theo chiều ngang. Làm méo theo
chiều dọc. Làm méo theo cả hai chiều.
Trường hợp này thì sao?
Vectơ nào là vectơ đặc biệt?
Con này khó nhá.
Đúng rồi. Chẳng có vecơ nào cả đúng
không? Vectơ 0 thì không được chấp nhận
rồi đúng không? Không có vecơ nào cả.
Tức là gì? Không phải ma trận nào cũng
có những tơ đặc biệt này. Có những ma
trận nó có và ma trận nó không đúng
không?
Tiếp này. Đây là méo như này là mé thử
dọc này được chưa? Đây là sharing được
chưa? Xoay dữ liệu được chưa? Xoay dữ
liệu như thế này.
Thì các bạn nhìn này. Nói rất nhiều về
những cái vecơ đặc biệt như vậy. Vì sao
chúng ta lại nói về cái điều đấy? Các
bạn nhìn này. Nhìn chung đúng không?
Nhìn chung khi chúng ta áp dụng một cái
phép biến đổi lên một vectơ. phép biên
đôi này thể hiện được qua phép nhân ma
trận đúng không? Thì vecơ kết quả sẽ
thay đổi cả về độ lớn và cả về phương so
với vectơ gốc. Ví dụ cái ảnh ở đây cái
ảnh gốc ban đầu như này các bạn có ba
vecơ, vectơ màu vàng, màu xanh và màu
trắng đúng không? Khi các bạn biến đổi
một cái phép nhân mà nhận đ cái phép
shearing này sharing đúng không? Thì các
bạn thấy là gì? Là cái vecơ màu vàng nó
thay đổi phương rồi. Độ lớn th không tôi
thay đổi không tôi không biết nhưng mà
ít mà về phương thay đổi đã. vàng thay
đổi, xanh thay đổi. Tuy nhiên nó cũng có
những ngoại lệ và những ngoại lệ này
người ta gọi nó là again vector. Được
chưa? Những cái vecơ mà sau khi các bạn
áp dụng cái vec biến đổi tuyến tính ấy
nó không bị thay đổi phương so với vecơ
góc ban đầu thì người ta gọi đó là những
cái vector. Và tất nhiên nếu u là một
vectơ thì k lần của u với k là một số
khác 0 nó cũng là vecơ đúng không? Nên
là về mặt bản chất nếu các bạn đã có thì
các bạn sẽ có vô số. Được chưa?
Thì bây giờ cái chúng ta đã biết là
again vector là những cái vecơ mà sau
khi các bạn nhân ma trận xong ấy, cái
vecơ output nó không bị thay đổi về mặt
phương. Độ lớn có thể thay đổi nhưng
phương không thể thay đổi. Thì bây giờ
ấy cái tỉ lệ giữa output, cái tỉ lệ giữa
output và input ấy nó đ sẽ được thể hiện
bằng một cái số lamda. Tức là gì? X là
input đúng không? Có vẻ a nh x là bằng
output mà a nh x là cùng phương với x.
Thế nên là chúng ta có thể biểu diễn là
gì? Là output thì bằng lamda nhân với x
đúng không? Thì lda được gọi là value và
v được gọi là vector. Các bạn chú ý nhá.
I value và vector nó phải đi theo cùng
cái ma trận. Cái ma trận a nó thay đổi
thì lập tức là value vectơ sẽ thay đổi
đúng không? Thì đây là cái ý nghĩa. Ngày
xưa các bạn đi học thì thường ta sẽ nói
về cách tính thôi đúng không? Nhưng ý
nghĩa là gì? Ý nghĩa là những cái vecơ
cái vecơ ấy mà nhân xong nó v không bị
thay đổi phương. Được chưa?
Cách tìm thì ngày xưa các bạn học rồi.
Cách tìm thì nó sẽ đây các bạn giải cái
định thức các thứ này đúng không? Đấy.
Thế nhưng mà tóm lại cái thứ quan nhất
là gì? Là ai vecơ cái gì có quan nhất là
gì? Là những cái vecơ mà sau khi các bạn
thể phép biến đổi ma trận nó sẽ không bị
thay đổi về mặt phương so với tờ input
đầu vào. Đấy. Thế vì sao chúng ta nói về
cái này? Tại vì nó sẽ là một cái bước
chúng ta sẽ phải làm khi chúng ta
tính cái PCA. Thế các bạn nhìn nhá. Quay
về quay về cái các cái bước mình sẽ nói
qua thôi. Sau này các bạn theo các bạn
sẽ dùng thư viện thôi. Tí mình sẽ showu
cho các bạn xem thử. Dùng thư viện thôi
chứ còn chả ai bây giờ người ta đi người
ta ngồi code từng bước cả. Các bạn nhìn
nhá. Đầu tiên này PCA ấ thì ví dụ tức là
cái ý tưởng của PCA là gì? Là dữ liệu
tôi đang ở không gian nhiều chiều tôi
muốn đưa về ít chiều. Ví dụ lúc ban đầu
dữ liệu của tôi nó là không gian bốn
chiều như thế này. Được chưa? Tôi có
nhiều sample, tôi có năm sample đi. Tôi
có bốn chiều này F1, F2, F3, F4 đúng
không? Không có label ở đây. PCA là một
thật toán. Xong này chúng ta sẽ tự hóa
này chúng ta học hai thuật toán, một là
Kmin Gring và hai là PCA. PCA là thuật
toán un tức là tôi không đảo độc đế đến
label cả. Được chưa? F1, S2, F34 đều là
feature của tôi. Thì bây giờ ấy đầu tiên
để tôi có thể tôi thể thực hiện PCA á
tức là tôi sẽ phải con tôi sẽ phải
convert transform cái rượu tôi sang
không gian bốn chiều mới từ bốn chiều cũ
sang bốn chiều mới. Sau tôi sẽ chọn
những cái chiều nào mà cái maximize cái
variance. Thì đểm đ như vậy thì bước đầu
tiên các bạn sẽ phải chuẩn hóa. Các bạn
sẽ cần phải chuẩn hóa các cái feature
của các bạn. Chuẩn hóa theo từng cột.
Tức là b gì ở đây các bạn có bốn cột là
bốn feature đúng không? Thì mỗi feature
các bạn sẽ đều phải tìm ra kỳ vọng với
cả đồ lệnh chuẩn. Sau các bạn lấy giá
trị gốc ban đầu trừ cho kỳ vọng chia cho
độ chuẩn. Được chưa? Ví dụ đây các bạn
tính đây kỳ vọng với độ chuẩn của từng
cột đây. Các bạn lấy giá trị gốc ban đầu
trừ cho kỳ vọng chia độ chuẩn các bạn ra
kết quả ở đây. Được chưa? Đầu tiên là
bước chuẩn hóa dữ liệu.
Sau khi chuẩn hóa rồi tôi sẽ tính ra cái
ma trận hiệp phương sai. Cái man trận
hiệp phương sai này thì các bạn cũng
không phải tính thủ công như mình nói
sao các bạn làm là các bạn một dòng nó
xong hết thư viện nó làm hết rồi. Cái
nhận hiệp phương sai này ấy thì nó nan l
ná như ma trận hệ số tương quan. Nó chỉ
khác mỗi một điều là gì? là ma trận hiều
số tương quan ấy thì đường chính nó sẽ
bằng 1. Còn phương sai thì không. Tại vì
hiệp phương sai là phiên bản nó không
được chuẩn hóa được chưa? M trận hiiệp
phương sai này các cái giá trị nhìn
chung là nó sẽ không có giới hạn được
chưa? Để hiệp phương sai nó như thế này.
Tiếp theo là gì? Là bây giờ khi mà các
bạn đã có một cái ma trận vuông này đây
ch đây cái ma trận hi sai là ma trận
kích thước 4/4 nó chưa đóng vai trò
giống y hệt những cái ma trận mà S với
R. Vậy các bạn nhìn đây này. Nó giống ch
những cái ma trận này này. Đấy chẳng qua
chúng ta trước là chúng ta ma trận kích
thước là 2 x 2 trong không gian hai
chiều. Đây là ma trận kích thước 4 x 4.
Được chưa? Bây giờ tôi có cái ma trận
hiệp phương sai này rồi. Đây này. Giá
trị như này đúng không? Ma trận này nó
là ma trận đối xứng. Được chưa? Thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ làm gì? Tôi sẽ tìm trị riêng
và vecơ riêng của cái ma trật hiệp
phương sai này. Được chưa? Trị riêng
vectơ riêng. Các bạn nhìn này. Ở đây
mình có bốn cái trị riêng và mình có bốn
cái vecơ riêng như này. Được chưa? Sau
đó thì mình sẽ sắp xếp theo cái thứ tự
là giảm dần của
giảm dần của chi tuyệt đối đúng không?
Ông nào chị đối to thì để đây may mắn là
cả bốn cả bốn ông nó đều là dương rồi
đúng không? Ông nào? Sau khi các bạn ở
đây các bạn tính ra được bốn cái bốn cái
value. Và từ một cái value này các bạn
sẽ được bốn cái vector đúng không? Cái
vecơ mình viết được dọc nhá. Đây v dọc 1
này 2 3 4 được không? Mình được bốn cái
value và bốn cái vector. Được chưa? Thế
bây giờ mình sẽ sắp xếp các cái vector
theo chiều giảm dần của value đúng
không? Đây ông nào value lớn đẩy lên
đầu, ông nào value nhỏ thì đẩy xuống
dưới. Mà các bạn nhớ là gì? Đúng không?
Đây đúng không? Cái ông này 2515 này.
Vectơ của nó này 0161 - 0 524 này đẩy
lên đây. Được chưa? Và các bạn nhớ là
gì? Chúng ta vừa nói rồi. Igen value có
ý nghĩa gì?
I value nó có ý nghĩa là nó là cái tỉ lệ
của output so với input. Tức là cái ông
mà có cái value là 2,515 ấy, tức là
vectơ output sẽ dài bằng 2,51 lần vectơ
input và nó cùng phương cùng hướng. Được
chưa? Cái ống tiếp theo 1,06565 tức là
gì? Tức là vectơ output nó sẽ dài hơn
vectơ output. À vectơ input là 1,065
lần. Còn hai ông kia nó sẽ bị nhỏ hơn.
Được chưa? Thì các bạn chú ý này, các
bạn có nhớ là vừa nãy khi mình nói về là
chúng ta trực văn hóa, chúng ta ưu tiên
cái chiều nào mà làm cho cái dượng nó
càng phân tán thì càng tốt đúng không?
Tức là gì? Không gian gốc có thể phân
tán ít, tôi muốn sau không gian mới phân
tán nhiều thì muốn phân tán ấy thì tôi
phải chọn những cái ông nào đây? Tôi
phải dựa vào những cái ông mà nó là tăng
kích thức của output đúng không? Hai ông
ban đầu cách nhau bé. Bây giờ tôi nhờ
cái an vector này tôi sẽ làm cho nó nó
chúng nó tách nhau ra đúng không? Tách
nhau ra. Tôi sẽ ưu tiên ông nào cái
value nó lớn như này được chưa? Thế bây
giả sử tôi muốn chức b hai chiều tức là
tôi chỉ giữ lại hai chiều thôi thì tôi
sẽ bỏ hai chiều cuối đi. Tôi chỉ giữa
hai hai chiều này thôi. Thì bây giờ hai
cái vecơ tướng các bạn dựng cạnh nhau
này nó sẽ một cái ma trận kích thước 4
x2. Được chưa? Thì sau này tôi muốn giảm
chiều dữ liệu của tôi ấy thì tôi chỉ lấy
cái ma trận gốc ban đầu kích thước là
nàng bốn cột tôi nhân với cái ma trận 4
x 2 này tôi sẽ ra được cái ma trận đầu
ra là như thế này n là n nh được chưa? C
nhận đầu ra là nó như thế này. Được
chưa? Input là n sample. Output vẫn n
sample nhưng mà input là bốn cột. Output
chỉ có hai cột thôi. Được chưa?
Thì đây đây là cái ví dụ chúng ta dùng
PC chúng ta trực quân hóa cái bộ em.
Bộ MNIS này các bạn có tổng cộng là 28 x
28 pixel.
Tức là 28 nh 28 là 784. Tức là chúng ta
coi mỗi mỗi một pixel là một là một
feature thì các bạn sẽ có 784 feature
tổng cộng. Thì chúng ta như thích là
chúng ta muốn trực quân hòa nó trong
không gian hai chiều hoặc ba chiều chúng
ta phải giảm chiều đi. Đây cho dùng PCA
tức chúng ta sẽ transform nó xong một
chiều không gian mới có 784 chiều chúng
ta sẽ chọn ra hai cái chiều mà cái độ
phân tán maximum đúng không? Cái hai
tương ứng với hai cái ông mà có hai cái
value lớn nhất đấy được chưa? Hai chiều
không gian ba chiều đây được chưa? Đây
cách để người ta chữ quán dữ liệu PCA là
một tụ toán người ta rất hay sử dụng để
chữ cá dữ liệu do cái thể chất là nó sẽ
maximiz mức độ phân tán của dữ liệu như
vậy. Được chưa?
Thử demo nhá. Thử demo nhá. Đây là hình
vẽ minh họa như vậy. Mình cho bạn demo
thì đây cho bạn code sẵn luôn. Đây bạn
chơ ờ
đâu ấy nhỉ?
Chừ mình một xíu nhá.
Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Các bạn chờ mình một tí
rất là dễ thôi nên chạy chạy trong chạy
trong sơn đã rất là dễ thôi. Đây các bạn
nhìn thử nhá.
Đây đầu tiên là mình sẽ
đây. Đầu tiên là mình sẽ tạo ra một cái
script mới nhá.
SVD
singular value decomposition.
Singular value decomposition là gì? Tôi
tách một cái ma trận lớn thành tích của
những cái ma trận con đúng không? Số
lượng sle nó ít hơn.
Ờ nó khác nhau. Nó khác nhau tức là SPD
là tôi sẽ biểu diễn cái input đồ vào
giấy dạ là tích của những cái vecơ con à
tách tích tích của những cái ma trận con
đúng không? Tôi biểu dữ cái ma trận lớn
tích của những ma trận con. Còn tức là
nó cũng có cái tính chất là giảm giảm
chiều nhưng mà kỹ thuật nó khác nhau.
PCA hay là hay là SPD nó chỉ là hai
trong số rất nhiều kỹ thuật giảm chiều
dữ liệu. Mỗi kỹ thuật nó sẽ nó sẽ đưa
vào nó sẽ đi vào những cái hướng khác
nhau nhá.
Ờ SVD à sẽ x các bạn chờ theo SP mới
nhá. Ví dụ mình ghi là PCA nhá. Được
chưa? Thế thì cái bộ Mis này thật ra là
trong thư viện SER nó cũng có người ta
cũng tích hợp sẵn vào rồi nhá. Ví dụ là
ờ
form skill này,
import này, dataset nhá. Thì thật ra là
trong cái bộ trong cái sing cái này
người ta tích hợp cái bộ rồi. X này y
này bằng đây datet
như này hoặc là hoặc là các bạn có một
cái gọi là chấm lootad này. Đây là bộ em
này
đây này. Nhưng cái bộ này thì ảnh nó bé
hơn nó bé hơn là người ta đã giảm giảm
cái nó đi rồi.
Nó là
được chưa? Cái bộ này nó sẽ bé hơn. Mình
mình lấy cái bộ bé thôi.
Đây có phải bộ không ấ nhỉ?
Class class không phải không phải. Đây
là bộ khác rồi. Bộ khác rồi. Không sao.
Thế bây giờ mình à notốt của em đi. Chấm
ho lấy bộ này cũng được vừ cho nó cho nó
ngắn nhá. Đúng không? Mình print này.
Print x.ssave này. I.shapve nhá. Nhìn
này.
Load à x các bạn return
return y = true này.
Đây bộ này tức là người ta đã làm phẳng
rồi. Nếu mà các bạn không có thì các bạn
lấy bộn thì thôi cũng được. Lấy bộn thì
cũng được. Đây đúng không? Load như này
mình sẽ làm phẳng nhá. Được chưa? Load
này cũng làm phẳng.
Th ra mình chỉ lấy bộ chế v con hói mình
chỉ lấy bộ trên thôi cũng được
thế này nhá. Được chưa? Lấy
lấy một x extr xang thôi cũng được
tại vì mình không cần y mình cũng không
cần i. Đây như này thôi. Được chưa? Xe
như này được chưa? Thế bây giờ sau khi
load xong các bạn sẽ dùng bắt đầu dùng
PCA nhá. Bây giờ mình ra cái shap đã
này. Green X train. Nhá được chưa?
À mình vẫn cần label xư các bạn. Vẫn cần
label để tí mình vẽ cái màu nó ra
đây. Label thì vẫn cần được chưa?
Như này nhá. Extrae là 60.000 à
60.784 đúng không? Hôm này 60.000 Thì
này. Thế bây giờ muốn dùng à
muốn dùng à muốn dùng muốn dùng PCA thì
mình lại làm một cái làm một cái pipline
như này này.
For sẽ skit learn
chp
này nhá. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
lại cho là hoặc là mình sẽ chỉ bạn một
cái option khác. Trong Sơn ấy nó có một
cái nó có một cái hàng nữa gọi là make
như này. Dùng nó tương tự cho thôi. Hai
option các bạn dùng cái nào cũng được.
Được chưa? Thì bây giờ sau khi bạn có
cái x này xong mình sẽ có một cái là đó
ví dụ mình gọi là PCA nhá. Mình sẽ tạo
pipeline. Nó cũng tương tự như là nó
cũng tương tự như là các bạn dùng pip
bình thường thôi. Hai cái tương tự nhau.
PCA mình chưa có mình chưa có import.
PCA thì trong c này form.dcosition
này. PCA được chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ muốn
vẽ không gian hai chiều mình gọi là PCA
TR to được chưa? Sau đấy mình sẽ bắt đầu
mình sẽ fit PCA fit xin và mình sẽ phải
train nữa. Bình thường PCA các bạn không
không cần nhãn nhưng mà ở đây tại vì
mình muốn visual mình muốn chư quân hóa
nó bằng màu khác nhau nên mình phải có
cái nhãn này mình mới chư con hóa được.
Được chưa? Thấy xong thì sau bây gi các
bạn sẽ
xong thì bây giờ tôi sẽ có một cái đây
là fit xy nhá đúng không? Xong tôi sẽ có
một cái nữa là tôi sẽ
xca
này tr nhá. Đúng không? Cái bước trên là
tôi huấn luyện mô hình. Tôi huấn luyện
cả cái bước này. Tôi huấn luyện cả hai
bước này. Dưới này tôi sẽ chỉ biến đổi
này thôi. PCA2D transform cái xray này.
Thế sau tôi bây giờ tôi sẽ mình sẽ mình
sẽ mình sẽ trực văn hóa mình sẽ trực văn
hóa cái a
mình sẽ trực quan hóa cái rượu này ra.
Chư văn hóa
đây m ph như này nhá.
Hai cái nó tương tự nhau các bạn ạ. Hai
cái nó tương tự nhau được chưa? Một cái
là các bạn apply thì các bạnẽ truyền vào
dạng một cái list. Còn đây các bạn
truyền vào dạng là các bạn vào những cái
tham số được chưa? Một ông truyền vào
list một cái tham số tương tự nhau thôi.
Ngay tương tự nhau nhá. Thế bây giờ mình
sau mình bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ add một
cái mình sẽ một cái đoạn như này
à form này m cái này các bạn không không
cần không cần nhớ đâu. Tí mình sẽ up cho
bạn mã nguồn nhá. Đây mình thêm một cái
đoạn như này được chưa? PCA à X PCA này
I ee nên mình cho vào đây
được chưa nhá. Bây giờ mình sẽ sẽ cho
các bạn xem thử nhá. Cái này các bạn
không còn nhớ đâu. Cái này tí mình sẽ
show cho các bạn. Cái này code này mình
cũng có ở trên mạng về thôi nhá.
Chứ văn hóa này lúc đầu nó không gian
784 chiều mình sẽ đưa nó về không gian
chỉ có hai chiều thôi.
Mình chỉ giữ lại hai chiều thôi. PCA ơ
chết quên mất chưa chưa có chưa có show
chưa có show
chấm
show như này
chưa show
số gian hai chiều nó lại như này
chờ một tí
đây không gian hai chiều như thế này
được chưa
cái bộ này thì nó đúng không các bạn
thấy không ờ vẫn Vẫn hơi khó nhìn một tí
đúng không? Các số 0 đây này nó đứng gần
nhau này đúng không? Ờ số 7 nó ở xa.
Được chưa? Cái bộ này nó hơi khó nhìn.
Mình có thể mình lấy mình lấy cái bộ nhỏ
hơn. Mình lấy cái bộ ban đầu vẫy mình
định lấy này.
Chỗ này đi mình sẽ lấy cái bộ nhỏ hơn
nhá. Mình sẽ lấy là x này y bằng
dat
chấm notis này. Được chưa? XY
x đây nếu bởi nó bé hơn nhìn nó dễ. Bộ
kia nó to quá.
Y này, X này, X này, X này các bạn không
cần phải reshapve nữa.
Y này, X chạy tử nhá. Vậy nhìn nó sẽ dễ
hơn tại vì là nó ít feature hơn. Đây
nó như kiểu như này được chưa? Đây là
trong không gian 2D nó như thế này. Được
chưa? Số này thì các bạn thấy này, rõ
ràng là các cái số đúng không? các cái
số mà nó giống nhau, ví dụ cùng là số
cùng là số bốn chẳng hạn, nó sẽ ở gần
nhau. Tất nhiên nó sẽ có những cái màu
bài điểm nó hơi xa xa một tí được không?
Màu đỏ với màu nâu nó gần nhau. Màu đỏ
là số 0. Màu nâu là số 6. Số 0 số 6 thì
nó có cái đoạn là cái vòng vòng tròn nó
giống nhau ấy. Nên là nhiều ông nó như
này. Được chưa? Đây là trong không gian.
Đây là trong không gian 2D. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ nếu mà các bạn muốn trong
không gian 3D thì các bạn thêm cái phần
này nữa. Đây là không gian 2D nhá. thêm
con gian 3D thì chỗ này sẽ thêm đoạn này
nữa này.
X này
Y này. Được chưa? Đây thiếu cái gì không
nhỉ?
Ví dụ không gian 3D nhá. Không gian 3D
thì chúng ta sẽ thay cái chiều này thôi.
Đây chỗ chiều bằng 3 ch là 3 nhá. Còn ở
dưới là mình sẽ có thêm một cái trục nữa
là cái scatter này này. Cái scatter mình
sẽ
x0, x1 và x2.
Nét thiếu cái gì không?
Hai như này nhá. Được chưa? Mình sẽ
và cái projection ở trên
sot này. 1 2 2 này. Được chưa?
Projection
3D như này không gian 3D các bạn nhìn
này. Không gian 3D trông như thế này.
Không gian 3D thì nó như này
và các bạn có thể các bạn tương tác với
nó được chưa? Tương tác này. Thấy chưa?
Mà D các bạn thấy gì? Tất nhiên là ví dụ
các bạn nhớ không? Các cái sample của số
0 nó ở gần nhau này. Số 5 à số 4 nó ở
gần nhau đúng không?
Số 6 gần nhau đây. Đây chính là ví dụ
cho dùng PCA đấy. Không gian gấp là 784
chiều. Tôi transform nó tôi đưa về số ba
chiều mà nó cái phân tán nó lớn nhất.
Được chưa? Màu hồng thì là số 7.
Số 7 nó hay bị lẫn số 7 số 1 nó gần nhau
tại vì số 7 số 1 nó đều có cái nét
thẳng. Được chưa? Cái đấy là toán PCA.
PCA tập toán người ta dùng rất là nhiều
trong trệc quân hóa dữ liệu. Dùng rất
rất nhiều.
Ok. Có bạn nào có câu hỏi thì không?
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi có b nào thắc mắc
gì không
thế nhá này chúng ta đã học hai toán
superv rồi một là c min clastering và
hai là PCA đúng không c min gring có
tính chất nó sẽ phân rượu ra về các cái
cụm sao cho các cái rượu trong cùng một
cụm nó tương đồng nhau rượu cụm này với
cụ kia nó khác nhau còn PCA dùng rất
nhiều trong giảm chiếu dữ liệu và đặc
biệt là dùng trong trực quân hóa dữ liệu
được chưa
rồi phần tiếp nhá phần tiếp nhá hôm nay
chúng ta chỉ toàn lý thuyết thôi
Tiếp này. À bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói về
chúng ta sẽ nói về cái phần lý thuyết
cuối cùng của cái của của cái khóa này
là liên quan đến các cái hệ thống gợi ý,
các cái recommendation system. Được
chưa? Các cái recommendation system. Hôm
nay chúng ta nói về lý thuyết buổi thứ
bảy tu sau thực hành được chưa?
Recommendation system.
Đầu tiên recommendation system nó là cái
gì? Đây là những cái hệ thống nó rất là
phổ biến trong những cái nền tảng về B2C
đúng không? Business to customer.
Khi mà các bạn ví dụ là các bạn có những
cái nền tảng gì phổ biến nhở? Các bạn có
Amazon này, các bạn có eBay này,
hệ thống gợi ý. Ừ, tế việc mình thi
thưởng hay dụng là gọi là khuyến nghị
đấy. Đúng không? Amazon này, eBay này,
cái gì nữa các bạn? Netflix này, ch là
Facebook đúng không? Rồi Spotify đúng
không? Tức là gì? Đ gợi ý nó là những
thành phần then chốt của những công ty
làm về mảng B2C. Tức là bây giờ một khi
mà chúng ta
một khi mà chúng ta đã tương tác với
những cái item trên cái nền tảng này thì
nền tảng họ sẽ dựa vào những cái tương
tác của chúng ta để họ có thể gợi ý cho
chúng ta những cái sản phẩm mà chúng ta
có thể chúng ta cũng quan tâm đúng
không? Nếu các bạn xem đã từng xem phim
trên Netflix rồi, các bạn sẽ biết là khi
bạn xem xong một cái bộ phim các bạn sẽ
nhìn những cái gợi ý là các bạn nên xem
phim gì đúng không? Hoặc các bạn khi mua
đồ trên những cái nền tảng trực tuyến
hoặc các bạn thanh toán xong thậm chí
các bạn mới chỉ cho vào giỏ hàng thôi
thì hệ thống nó cũng sẽ gợi ý bạn những
cái sản phẩm có thể các bạn các bạn quan
tâm đúng không? Thì đấy chính là những
cái ví dụ của những hệ thống gợi ý hay
là recommendation system đúng không? Đây
là những thành phần rất là quan trọng
trong hầu hết các cái công ty về mặt
B2C. Nhiệm vụ là gợi ý những cái sản
phẩm và đưa ra những cái gợi ý mà có thể
sử dụng họ sẽ quan tâm. Hối với các cái
công ty lớn B2C như là Facebook, Amazon,
Apple, Netflix, Google, Spotify đều có
những cái hệ thống gợi ý tốt nhất thế
giới.
Thế đúng không? Người dùng tương tác với
sản phẩm tương tác đây, không chỉ là mua
có gì các bạn chỉ là thả like, các bạn
xem và các bạn dislike thôi, nó cũng là
tương tác rồi đúng không?
Thế thì nói về các cái hệ thống gợi ý nó
có rất nhiều cách phân loại khác nhau
nhưng mà tuy nhiên nó sẽ có bốn cái loại
chính. Bốn cái loại chính. Cái loại đầu
tiên gọi là popular popular hoặc là
popularity base là dựa trên sự phổ biến.
Cái là cái dễ nhất. Tiếp theo là chúng
ta sẽ có ờ content based featuring tức
là lọc dựa trên nội dung. Thứ ba là
featuring là lọc cộng tác và thứ tư là
hybrid là kết hợp cả hai ông này với
nhau. Đây là bốn cái loại chính. Chúng
nó sẽ đi qua từng loại một. Càng loại
sau càng phức tạp. Các cái thứ tự mình
kể từ nãy giờ popular rồi content rồi
collaborative rồi hybrid là độ phức tập
tăng dần. Đầu tiên các bạn cho mình hỏi
nhá. Đầu tiên các bạn cho mình hỏi này.
Bây giờ ấy giả sử bây giờ một cái nền
tảng ví dụ như là Netflix đi đúng không?
Bây giờ giả sử bây giờ mình mới tạo tài
khoản trước đây mình chưa hề tương tác
gì với hệ thống. Hệ thống nó chẳng biết
gì về mình cả. Bây giờ mình tạo tài
khoản nó cũng chỉ biết mỗi tên của mình
thôi. Nó không biết một cái gì khác. Thì
bây giờ với những cái người dùng mà nạp
đầu xả nạp, những cái dùng mà lần đầu
login vào hệ thống chưa biết gì phải họ
thì theo các bạn bây giờ hệ thống muốn
gợi ý ví dụ như là Netflix đi nó muốn
gợi ý phim đi thì với những cái người
dùng mới tinh như vậy theo các bạn là hệ
thống nó sẽ nên gợi ý những cái phim như
thế nào?
À training đúng rồi đúng không? Bây giờ
tôi không biết gợi ý gì tôi cứ lương
training thôi. Đúng không? những cái ông
nạp đầu cái ông mà chưa hiề tương tác
với hệ thống hệ thống nó không biết gì
về những ông này thì tôi cứ chêning mà
phang thôi đúng không hệ thống này đây
là cái bước mà
gần như là những cái hệ thống mới bao
giờ nó cũng làm như này thì các bạn lần
đầu các bạn vào một cái trang thế bao
giờ nó cũng làm cách cách này cách này
sẽ gửi ý những cái sản phẩm về hoặc là
những cái dịch vụ mà đang phổ biến nhất
hiện nay trên nền tảng ưu điểm cái cận
này nó là đơn giản là rất là đơn giản
đúng không cứ ông nào đang top chaing
tôi gợi ý thôi
Nhưng mà nhược điểm nó là gì?
Nhược điểm cái cận này là gì các bạn?
Nh điểm là
điểm là gì?
Nó sẽ không có tính cá nhân hóa. Nó sẽ
không có tính cá nhân hóa. Mình hay mẹ
mình login vào đều gợi ý như thế đúng
không? Mình login vào cũng gợi ý như vậy
mà mẹ mình login vào gợi ý cũng đi chẳng
chả khác gì cả.
Được chưa? Không có sự cá nhân hóa.
Thường cái hệ cái hệ thống hệ thống này
ấy ta sẽ chỉ dùng trong cái giai đoạn
đầu thôi. Tức là gì? Với những người
dùng mới khi mà chúng ta hệ thống chưa
có dữ liệu gì về họ thì hệ thống sẽ chạy
cái popularity based recommendation
system này đúng không? Để qua cái giai
đoạn warup ban đầu.
Nâng cao hơn một chút là hệ thống
content based content based rất là đơn
giản. Các bạn nhìn cái hình minh họa này
thôi. Tức là gì? Hệ thống nó sẽ đánh giá
cái đặc tính của cái item
ờ mà các bạn vừa tương tác ấy. Ví dụ bây
giờ mình lên trên Shopee chẳng hạn đúng
không? Mình bây giờ mình mới xem một cái
laptop thì bây giờ hệ thống sẽ xem là
laptop là thuộc về cái category cái cái
nhánh là về đồ khoa học kỹ thuật đúng
không? Vì nó hệ thống nó sẽ gợi ý là à
ông này đang tìm một laptop thì chắc là
ông này cũng sẽ cần những cái thứ như
kiểu là bàn phím rời, tai nghe, chuột,
chuột các thứ vân vân đúng không? Thì
đấy chính là cái ý nghĩa của content
base featuring được chưa? Hoặc là bây
giờ một người dùng xem rất nhiều những
bộ phim siêu anh hùng. Thế thì bây giờ
ông nào mà xem medical thì tôi sẽ dự ý
tôi sẽ gửi ý những cái phim cũng trong
cái chủ đề về siêu anh hùng như vậy.
Được chưa? Thế cái cách thức này rất là
đơn giản. Các bạn chỉ cần biết được cách
sắp xếp các cái item vào trong các cái
nhóm thôi đúng không? Nhóm kỹ thuật,
nhóm trang điểm, nhóm làm đẹp, nhóm sức
khỏe đúng không? Thì bây giờ người dùng
họ dùng cái sản phẩm nào các bạn gợi ý
đúng cái nh tất nhiên một sản phẩm nó có
thể nó thuộc về nhiều nhóm, một sản phẩm
vừa có thể thuộc về nhóm kỹ thuật vừa
thuộc về nhóm giải trí không vấn đề gì.
Bây giờ người dùng mà họ mua một cái a
một cái a máy tính bà vừa là kỹ thuật
vừa là giải trí, tôi sẽ gửi ý cả những
cái đồ kỹ thuật và cả những đồ giải trí.
Được chưa? Đây cách gửi ý rất là đơn
giản.
Tuy nhiên cách thức cận này nó cũng có
nhược điểm.
Nhược điểm của cách tiếp tích cận này là
gì các bạn?
Cách tiếp cận này ưu điểm là đơn giản
nhưng nhược điểm là gì?
Giảm đa dạng.
Có thể nói rõ một chút được không?
Có vẻ có ý đúng rồi. Nhưng này rõ hơn
một chút được không? Các tiếp cận này có
nhiều điểm gì?
Như điểm gì?
Như điểm gì hả các bạn?
Thế này nhờ điểm gì các bạn?
Rồi bạn à bạn Thành phải nói đúng rồi.
Tức là ấy ví dụ một cái ông nào xem phim
siêu anh hùng ấy thì hệ thống nó suốt
đời cứ gợi ý phim siêu anh hùng. Tức là
nó không có cái sự đa dạng, nó không có
cái sự mới mẻ khi mà gợi ý. Được chưa?
Gợi ý tôi chả có gì mới mẻ. Tôi thích
xem hoạt hình suốt ngày nó gợi ý phim
hoạt hình. Tôi thích xem phim tôi thích
xem phim Hàn Quốc suốt đời nó cứ gợi ý
phim Hàn Quốc. Nó chả có cái gì mới mẻ
cả đúng không? Và những cái không mới mẻ
như vậy thì toàn những cái mà các bạn
gợi ý những cái mà có khi là người ta
cũng biết rồi đúng không? Cái sức mạnh
của những hệ thống gợi ý là gì? Là nhiều
khi người sẽ giúp người dùng khám phá ra
cái những cái thứ mà họ họ còn không
biết là họ thích cơ. Nhưng mà cái tệ này
người ta không làm được như vậy. Được
chưa? Thì cái nhược điểm là gì? Nó không
cái sự đa dạng cho những cái gợi ý đúng
không? Các cái thứ mà các bạn gợi ý nó
đều thuộc cái chủng loại cả không có gì
đặc biệt, không có gì mới mẻ cả. Được
chưa?
Cái thứ hiệu thứ ba
VIP pro hơn một chút là lọc cộng tác.
Collaborative featuring. Đây là hợi cái
hệ thống gợi ý item dựa trên sự tương
quan, sự tương đồng giữa các cái người
dùng. Các bạn có thể hiểu là gì? Là ở
các cái hệ thống này thì một item sẽ
được recommend tới một người dùng dựa
trên những người dùng có hành vi tương
tự. Ví dụ đi có ba người dùng là người
dùng A B C. Ba người này đều thích nghe
nhạc của Sơn Tùng NTP. Thế thì ngoài ra
hệ thống cũng biết được rằng là hai
người dùng B và C ấy cũng thích các cái
bài nhạc của Mono nhưng mà hệ thống hoàn
toàn chưa có thông tin gì về việc là
liệu người dùng A có thích nghe nhạc của
Mono hay không. Thì dựa vào thông tin
của nhóm của những cái người dùng tương
tự là B về C này thì hệ thống nó sẽ dựa
đoán rằng là A có thể cũng thích nghe
nhạc của Mô đấy và nó sẽ gửi ý những cái
bàiá này cho cho người A đúng không? Thì
đây là lọc cộng tác. Cái lọc cộng tác
này thì nó sẽ đa nó sẽ phức tạp hơn. Tại
vì sao?
Lọc dựa theo nội dung ấy các bạn chỉ cần
quan tâm đến chính các bạn thôi. Các bạn
không cần phải quan tâm đến ông khác.
Nhưng mà lọc cộng tác các bạn quan tâm
đến những người khác nữa. Những người
khác họ có cái sở thích gì cũng phải
quan tâm. Được chưa?
Và cái cuối cùng là gì? Là tôi kết hợp.
Tôi kết hợp cả hai ông lại với nhau. Tức
là gì? Tôi cùng cái input đó tôi cho co
cả hai cái bộ lọc. Lọc dễ nội dung và
lọc dễ cộng tác. Sau tôi kết hợp lại tôi
sẽ có cách nào đấy? Tôi gắn điểm, tôi
tính điểm, cuối cùng tôi ra cái kết quả
cuối cùng của tôi đúng không? Thì đây là
cách kiểu phối hợp nhau. Thật ra thì sau
này ấ khi mà các bạn vào những công ty
mà các bạn có những cái hệ thống gợi ý
này ấy thì các bạn gần như sẽ không bao
giấu chuyện, các bạn phải sự từ đầu đâu.
Thường các bạn vào công ty là họ đã có
sẵn hệ thống rồi. Các bạn chỉ vào các
bạn maintain, các bạn duy trì, các bạn ờ
cải thiện chúng nó thôi chứ còn ít khi
cái chuyện các bạn phải sự từ đầu lắm.
Tại vì sự từ đầu nó sẽ có cái giai đoạn
các bạn phải tích dữ liệu rất là mất
thời gian. Được chưa?
đấy là một vài cái cái hướng th cận phổ
biến của hệ thống gợi ý. Thế thì ờ gợi ý
sản phẩm như vậy. Cái bài toán gợi ý này
nó là một cái bài toán ờ ăn unv nó không
có nhãn. Nó không có nhãn
mà nó chỉ có dữ liệu về
những cái sự tương tác giữa người dùng
với sản phẩm thôi. Thì các bạn thấy là
các bạn thấy là trong cái bài toán
recommendation system ấy chúng ta có hai
nhóm đối tượng chính là người dùng và
sản phẩm.
Đầu vào của hệ thống là những cái thông
tin về người dùng và sản phẩm. Và những
cái thông tin về người dùng ấy có thể là
thông tin về giới tính, về tuổi, về nghề
nghiệp, về vị trí địa lý, về thời điểm
truy cập trang web, về trình duyệt, về
thiết bị. Những cái thông tin thị này
thường nó sẽ biến đổi theo thời gian.
Hôm nay tôi dùng web, mai tôi dùng
mobile. Hôm nay tôi vào buổi sáng, mai
tôi vào buổi tối. Được chưa? Đây những
cái thông tin về người dùng là thông tin
về user ấy. Được chưa? Thế còn những thứ
thông tin về sản phẩm có thể là loại mặt
hàng, nơi sản xuất, thời điểm sản xuất
và những thông tin này thì thường nó ít
thay đổi, thường ít thay đổi, thường nó
cố định. Được chưa? Thế thì thật ra ấy
với cái bài toán này ấ nếu mà gọi là
nhãn ấy chúng ta cũng có nhãn đấy, cũng
có label đấy. Thì nhãn của bài toán này
nó chính là những cái hành vi, chính là
những cái sự tương tác mà người dùng làm
đối với sản phẩm. Được chưa? Ví dụ như
là gì? đã xem, đã mua, đã cho vào giỏ
hàng vân vân thì dữ liệu của bài toán
recomendation system thường sẽ được thể
hiện trong một cái ma trận gọi là
utility magic này. Utility magic mình
cũng không biết là dây tiếng Việt dịch
như nào tại vì cái từ utility mà dây
tương tiếng Việt thì nó không phải nó
không thể hiện cái ý nghĩa của ma trận
này. Nói chung đây là cái ma trận thể
hiện là cái sự tương tác giữa người dùng
với sản phẩm. Tương tác có thể là
positive, có thể negative đúng không? Có
thể là tôi thích, tôi ghét sản phẩm đấy.
Được chưa?
Thế thì mỗi hàng đúng không? Cái bá nhận
này, mỗi hàng thể hiện một người dùng,
mỗi cột thể hiện một sản phẩm đúng
không? Các cái ô cái chấm tròn này thể
hiện là ờ tôi đã có cái thông tin gì đấy
về việc là người dùng này họ tương tác
với sản phẩm rồi, có thể là thích, có
thể là ghét. Thế bài toán đặt ra là gì?
Là tôi phải dự đoán được cái mức độ quan
tâm của người dùng tới sản phẩm tương
ứng đến những cái sản phẩm khác đúng
không? T gì tôi phải dự đoán được những
cái ô mà chưa có chấm tròn. Đấy, được
chưa? Thế thì
cái bài toán
gợi ý sản phẩm hệ thống gợi ý này ấy nó
tương đương nó liên quan đến cái bài
toán gọi là hoàn thiện ma trận. Tức là
gì? Tôi càng hoàn thiện cái ma trận này,
tôi càng điền được vào những cái ô bị
khuyết ấy thì tôi càng có nhiều gợi ý để
tôi gợi ý cho người dùng. Được chưa? Hay
nói khác là gì? Nhiệm vụ các th của cái
hệ thống gợi ý là gì? Là phải điền vào
cái ô còn trống.
Thế ở đây mình sẽ nói qua cho các bạn
một chút về một vài những cái thách thức
mà những cái hệ thống gợi ý nó sẽ gặp
phải. Tức là một vài những cái thách
thức mà các bạn sẽ gặp phải khi mà chúng
ta thực hiện cái bài toán điều chố chấm
này. Đầu tiên là cái việc xây dựng những
cái chấm đỏ những cái chấm này hay là
việc là xây dựng nhãn.
Cái vấn đề ấy là cái sự tương tác giữa
người dùng và sản phẩm ấy không phải lúc
nào nó cũng dễ để các bạn có thể thu
thập được. Các bạn tưởng tượng nhá, các
cái nhãn này, các cái chấm đỏ này nó thể
hiện ờ nó có thể được thể hiện một cách
tường minh. Ví dụ như là người dùng mua
sản phẩm cho vào giỏ hàng, họ xem sản
phẩm họ like, họ thả dislike cũng thế
hoặc là họ đánh giá là số sao bao nhiêu.
Được chưa? Nhưng cái nhãn này ấ thì
người ta gọi đó là phản hồi tường minh
hay người ta gọi là explicit feedback.
Phản hồi tường minh là nghĩ phản hồi rất
là rõ ràng, rất là clear rồi. Không có
cái gì phải bàn luận, phải tranh cãi cả.
Họ mua nghĩa là họ cần, họ thả like
nghĩa là họ thích, họ dislike nghĩa là
họ không thích, họ cho vào giả cho vào
giỏ hàng nghĩa là họ quan tâm. Nó là rõ
ràng clear rồi. Được chưa? Và nó là và
người dùng họ chủ động họ cho chúng ta
cái thông tin đấy. Được chưa? Thế nhưng
mà tuy nhiên
tuy nhiên nếu mà chỉ trông đợi vào những
cái tương tác thực sự chủ động của người
dùng ấy thì sẽ cái màn nhện rất là lâu.
Tại vì là một ngày họ cho được mấy sản
phẩm đâu đúng không? họ họ tương thác
mấy sản phẩm đâu đúng không? Họ ít. Thế
do đó người ta sẽ có cách khác là gì?
Người ta sẽ có cách khác là tôi sẽ cần
phải xây dựng những cái nhãn này dựa
trên những cái phản hồi ẩn hay người ta
gọi là implicit feedback từ người dùng.
Ờ
ví dụ như là gì? Ví dụ là người dùng ví
dụ có để họ không mua hàng nhưng mà họ
có để họ click vào sản phẩm hoặc họ dành
để họ đọc về nó đúng không? hoặc là
nhiều khi họ dùng người dùng họ chỉ dừng
lại đế họ họ họ họ họ xem một thời gian
rồi họ đi tiếp thì đấy cũng là cái phản
ứng rất là tốt. Và một cái nữa là gì?
Một cái nữa ấy là có rất nhiều hệ thống
ấy để có thể xây dựng cái ban nhậ này
nhanh hơn họ sẽ là một cái thứ là họ sẽ
làm một cái survey hoặc một cái kiểu cái
khảo sát về questionaire. Tức là khi
người dùng lần đầu đăng nhập vào hệ
thống hoặc là ví dụ các bạn vào những
cái trang ờ ngày xưa các bạn có mấy cái
trangue TV cái trang về phim ấy đúng
không? Các bạn đăng nhập trước khi bạn
xem phim nó sẽ bắt trả lời một cái bảng
năm câu hỏi kiểu như thế thì có rất
nhiều hệ thống nó sẽ tức là với những
người dùng lần đầu và hệ thống họ sẽ bắt
người dùng là trả lời một vài những câu
hỏi ngắn thôi đúng không? Có thể có ba
năm câu. Cái cách này có cái ưu điểm là
sẽ tôi sẽ thu dập một cái lượng rượu rất
là lớn. Tôi sẽ thu dậm một cái lượng
rượu về nhãn rất là lớn. Tại vì mỗi
người dùng trả lời năm câu hỏi thôi là
các bạn đã có một đống dữ liệu rồi.
Nhưng cách này nó cũng có tồn tại những
cái nhược điểm. Các bạn cho mình hỏi
này, cái việc mà
hỏi người dùng một vài câu hỏi và yêu
cầu họ trả lời như vậy, theo các bạn khi
mà chong thực tế nó sẽ có những cái
nhược điểm gì?
Nhược điểm gì các bạn?
Đúng, người dùng khó chịu cái nhất. User
experience
trải nghiệm người dùng khó chịu là cái
thứ nhất. Thứ hai đúng rồi. Ví dụ trả
lời qua loa. Ví dụ như mình mình cứ trả
lời yes hết hoặc là cho năm sao hết đúng
không? Giống kiểu mình đi ăn ở ngoài đấy
mình cho năm sao tốt hay không cho năm
sao hết được chưa họ có thể dùng họ trở
lấy qua loa họ không trở lấy thực sự và
dụ nó sẽ làm ảnh hưởng cái trải nghiệm
của người dùng được chưa đấy là cái thứ
nhất thứ hai nữa là gì là dữ liệu nó sẽ
bị lệch tức là gì có những cái một vài
sản phẩm rất là hot nó sẽ có rất nhiều
dữ liệu, nhiều người tương tác với nó và
những cái có có có những cái sản phẩm mà
mà chả có ai tương tác cả các bạn hiểu
một cái hệ thống ví dụ trên Amazon hoặc
là eBay họ có hàng triệu hàng chục triệu
sản phẩm những sản phẩm mà không ai động
vào không có thông tin gì về nó cả. Được
chưa? Thế
và thông thường ấy cái giai đoạn ban đầu
cái giai đoạn nó rất là lâu giai đoạn
cái giai đoạn war up ban đầu t giai đoạn
ban đầu các bạn chưa có nhiều dữ liệu ấy
thì các bạn sẽ chờ dữ liệu nó bắp lên
rất là lâu. Được chưa? Thế cái việc mà
có một cái nữa là cái khó là co start
tức là khởi đầu lạnh. Khởi đầu lạnh tức
là gì? Tức là khi mà lúc ban đầu ấy dữ
liệu nó ít quá dữ liệu ít thì bây giờ
chưa có ai tương tác với hệ thống. Tôi
chưa thông tin gì cả. Tôi cũng chả biết
tôi gợi ý cái gì đúng không? Thì cái câu
start này nó sẽ khiến cho những cái hệ
thống ban đầu hệ thống mà chưa có nhiều
dữ liệu rất là khoan trong quá trình vận
hành ban đầu. Tất nhiên sau này các b
chạy nó chạy lâu rồi thì nó sẽ khác
nhưng mà ví như kiểu Amazon về eBay họ
chạy lâu rồi thì nó khác nhưng mà cái hệ
thống chạy lần đầu thì nó sẽ rất là khó
khăn để nó vượt qua cái giai đoạn này.
Cần rất nhiều thông tin, cần rất nhiều
dữ liệu. Được chưa?
Thế và ngoài ra thì trong thực tế các
bạn sẽ còn phải quan tâm đến cái tốc độ
xử lý nữa. Tôi gợi ý được nhưng mà tôi
xử lý lâu quá một cái một recomment cho
mọi người. Tôi phải chạy 10 phút chẳng
hạn thì ai mà chờ được đúng không? Thế
thì đấy là một vài những cái lý thuyết
về một vài những cái khó khăn mà chúng
tôi sẽ gặp phải trong những cái hệ thống
thực tế. Tất nhiên chúng ta hôm chúng ta
thực hành chưa đến mức khó khó như vậy
đâu. Chúng ta sẽ thực hành mu một cái mô
hình đơn giản thôi. Nhưng mà sau này các
bạn khi bạn đi làm thực tế các bạn sẽ có
những cái khó khăn như vậy mà các bạn sẽ
phải đối mặt nếu mà cái hệ thống nó đang
cho nên ạ nó đang nó đang còn trẻ nó
đang còn mới bắt đầu nhá.
Ok có nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Hôm nay chúng ta đã đi xong lý thuyết về
quá này rồi. Buổi sau chúng ta sẽ thực
hành và những buổi sau mấy buổi cuối
mình sẽ có một vài cái topic khác ngoài
ờ các cái khóa trước nó học chậm hơn thì
nó sẽ không mình sẽ không nói đến các
đoạn đấy. Nhưng mà có này chúng ta sẽ đi
một chút về về deep learning nữa nhá.
Ok. Thế ờ không nói với docker cũng
được. Nếu mà nếu mà nhiều bạn quan tâm
nói với doer cũng được cũng được nhá.
Ok. Có nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Kiểu này cái này chúng ta không tự thuap
được mà nó phải dựa vào hệ thống dựa vào
cái tương tác của người dùng. Nó không
phải giống như kiểu những cái bộ rượu
như kiểu bộ di các bạn có thể chủ động
đi được. Đây là các bạn phải dựa vào
tương tác của người dùng chứ không phải
tự nhiên mà có đâu.
Không th nó dựa thật người dùng với bộ
da tôi để tôi tự đi tôi thu thập tôi
đánh nhãn. Ok nhưng mà đây phải có người
dùng vào
17 buổi các bạn ạ. Sau khóa này nó sẽ có
hai hướng. Bạn nào thích cái bảng
computer vision như mình thì các bạn sẽ
theo cái hướng là deing for computer
vision. Còn bạn nào các bạn thích theo
cái hướng mảng NLP, LM agent các bạn
theo cái mảng kia. Mình được dạy cả hai
thôi nhưng mà nó có hai hướng như vậy.
Một hướng là chuyên làm việc với text và
một chướng chuyên làm việc với ảnh với
cả video.
Kh này 17 17 buổi nhưng mà hôm nà có một
hôm mình dạy các bạn thiếu mất một tiếng
nên là chúng ta sẽ phải có một cái buổi
nửa buổi nữa nhá.
Ok.
Ok thế thôi các bạn nhá. Chúc các bạn ăn
tối ngon miệng. Chúc các bạn buổi tối
vui vẻ, tuần mới học tập và làm việc
hiệu quả nhá. Tuần sau chúng ta lại gặp
nhau nhá.
Ơ mọi người nha.
M.